[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
hey what's up everybody welcome back
to the saturday morning
3d live stream
and today we are creating that piece of
art you saw in the countdown
live from scratch
from start to finish and i'm gonna try
and do it
as fast as possible um
one of the reasons
i mean there's a lot of reasons why this
art and why i'm doing this but
i'm trying to learn unreal engine 5
i've been trying to learn it for years
and i'm really tired of
the number of tutorials on youtube
that show you a really nice piece of art
but then they don't show you how it's
done they'll do an overview but they
don't get into the details like we all
want to know how it's done
because i know i want to know how it's
done specifically so that's why i'm
going to show you guys how to do it this
today step by step
uh no added plugins all for free in
unreal engine 5.
um
i'm such a sucker for these environments
let's just hop
right into it and i'm gonna show you
guys uh what is up here let me do a
couple of switcheroonies
and
boom you all should be seeing this yeah
so
this is the scene you know bam bam bam
we're going to create
um we're going to talk about the water
we're going to talk about some foliage
we're going to talk about some rocks i'm
talking about this lighting's overcast
lighting which is a big part of it
um
and but first we're going to talk about
the reference right so
these pictures were inspired well not
inspired me my buddy adam the guy who
wrote the music uh the ambient music
that you all heard at the beginning of
the stream
we went to newfoundland
to
st john's newfoundland specifically um
to capture fog on film
and we went to a place called signal
hill
in st john's and this is signal hill i
think there was like a battle of signal
hill at one point
and
it was beautiful very windy very very
windy y'all may have seen the mortality
run
art that i did a while back uh with the
car in the ocean and the factory in the
back
if we were to take this camera
and pan to the left you would see that
ocean
this is cape spear
very very close to signal hill
as you can tell by the weather the
lighting et cetera um
so what i'm doing is i'm using my own
photography as reference and this is the
the shot that i took at signal hill
in st john's newfoundland and we're
going to recreate this today as quickly
as possible we're just going to get
through it we're going to get to it then
i'm going to go over all the challenge
winners
um for the weekly challenge which
happened to be
monument as well this is kind of a
monument in its own so let's get to it
this is pure f by the way link's in the
description i got you a link to unreal
engine 5 if you want to download it and
mess with you know some environments
along with me here today um and a link
to pureref this is how i'm looking at my
uh reference imagery which will just be
off to the right side of the screen
um
we're just starting from scratch guys
we're gonna get into it um let's uh
let's
go file
new level i'm going to start with basic
we're going to create this thing
uh yeah yeah yep yep yep
ctrl shift s or rather let's just file
save as
we're going to save current level as
signal hill round two
signal
hill
round two
um we got a super chat render rise
what's up yo uh thank you very very much
you say loving the content uh one of my
greatest inspirations oh gosh oh gosh
uh keep it up keep doing some good stuff
uh keep getting inspired i appreciate it
we got a lot of people in the chat here
today we got 584 people popping off what
is up everybody
um
i see we got visual one of the
moderators up in here i always got
sodamonte in my ear behind the scenes so
he's hanging out with us through the
entire stream
um these are the moderators on the
creative clinton discord server linked
in the description also below
um
what's up everybody we got mr ants
what's up mr ants chillin from india
yeah zeus creates good to see i loved
your art that you created for this
weekly challenge let's get into it y'all
here to learn
so let's learn all right we started that
new level right if you hold right click
and use wasd you can fly around q and e
will
boom up and boom down as well you got
some icons here this is some uh
basically our different
we got some lighting essentially we got
some volumetric clouds
chilling up in here um we got some
sunlight uh what else do we got we got a
skylight you know if we turn off the
skylight you can see all these things
kind of do different stuff uh william
foshea actually released an incredible
tutorial yesterday
it is lighting for beginners in unreal
engine it's a 44 minute tutorial um
definitely check it out after this
and he goes over all this stuff and i'm
gonna be you i'm gonna be using all
these things that he goes over in that
tutorial so if i think if i hit ctrl l
and use yeah i can kind of move the sun
around and stuff and you can see how it
hits uh
it affects the clouds differently this
is super super powerful this is unreal
engine 5 and where it's default set to
lumen
when you open up the program there's a
couple things i didn't show you guys
when you first start a program i'm in a
i believe i'm in a uh
it's either tv and film or games it
honestly doesn't matter
but i started with ray tracing clicked
on
in case we wanted to switch to ray
tracing i'll get into that a little bit
later
um but the first thing that we want to
do is
look at our reference and ask ourselves
okay well we have to figure out this
overcast lighting and we need to figure
out like
what elements are going to go into our
scene i'm going to be using quick soul
mega scans because it comes free with
unreal engine 5. believe it or not it's
insane how
accessible epic games makes all of this
um
and then there's some shrubs that we're
going to like paint on we'll talk about
painting on the shrub brush and
everything
and
i'll quickly model this little totem
here in c4d you can do it in blender
whatever you all want uh simon what's up
dude thank you for the super chat you've
been watching since corridor since you
were nine or ten you're 20 now that's a
long that's a straight up decade keep
doing your thing love the vibe thank you
simon
much appreciate it thanks for being here
thanks for learning with me
um let's make this easy for you guys
let's make this easy so
we're in our scene like i said right
click wasd to move around
um the first thing i'll want to do is
kind of lock my camera figure out what
my camera is what i'm looking at
and i'll probably start with
uh
let's see i'll probably start
uh with that totem that i modeled i
already have it um that's that'll show
me my scale
so i mean otherwise let's see let's do
where would you be mesh
monument b2 i'll just drag this out
right into
the middle we can have our
we can just zero this out over here on
the right side on our transform values
so we kind of know our scale this is
something that i made in c4d
beforehand
um you can place whatever you want here
you can place a mannequin you can place
a box this way we just know what our
scale is and i know this is just a
little bit smaller than a human
um so like i said we want to get our
camera going
first off figure out
what we need to fill
with stuff with assets
because we only need to fill so much we
don't need to fill the entire
environment that's going to take too
long we just need to fill a certain
we need to fill this much
right that's that's as much as we need
to fill um
so i'm going to go over to the top left
here place actors and type in camera
and we should have a cinematic camera
actor right here i think if we type cine
it might be a little easier
boom the cine camera actor i'ma drag
this out
and
you see a little preview here i'm going
to right click it in our outlier or our
outliner apologies and pilot this thing
so now when we right click and move
around with wasd we're in a nice
cinematic camera i'm going to leave
these settings pretty close to default
because it kind of matches already what
i'm doing but on the bottom right you'll
see your camera settings so if we scroll
down here to the film back it's it's set
set to 16 9
digital film and that's basically
you know your 1920x1080
standard aspect ratio you can change
these and
work on different aspect ratios
um type in your own
this is imax
right but 16 9 digital film
is totally fine for what we need um
let's go ahead and set the focus right
because we want the focus to be on this
all right on this this monument on this
totem so if we go to
focus settings we can change that to
tracking
right set that to tracking and then
under
actor to track i can just eye drop
this monument and now no matter where i
go if i
check the d uh draw debug tracking focus
plane we can see that our focus plane
is right there
that's a box for some reason there we go
no matter where i move
the focus is always
on this totem
or the monument or this pillar whatever
i don't even know what this thing is
um
so we got that set all right i like our
focal length of 35 you can you know we
can do 25 if you want see a little bit
more that's not bad
you know somewhere somewhere in here yo
mto what is up thank you very much for
that super chat very generous of you
and no problem no problem i just hope
you guys are learning something we're
all trying to make nice environments
right in unreal engine
um and it's a pretty confusing program
at first
but once you're in it's actually not
that bad especially with quicksole it
makes it really easy
all right so we got our camera set up
generally right
um i'm going to clean this up a little
bit so we have a lighting folder i also
like to select the camera let's let's
make a post process volume really quick
so just trust me on this we're going to
need this thing post process volume
we'll drag it into our scene
and in the
attributes
box here the details panel i'm going to
type unbound and unbound essentially if
we check this box infinite extent it
doesn't matter where we are in the scene
this post post process volume will
affect the entire
scene okay
um
okay
i'll select the post process volume hold
ctrl select the cine camera actor
click on this folder plus folder and i'm
going to make a camera folder
yup yup and then i'm going to select the
floor and this totem
make a folder i'm going to call this geo
for geometry just so we have everything
kind of tidied up a little bit
from here let's see if we can't um
get more of an overcast
look
for our lighting
oh snap we got william foshay up in here
son
oh i was just talking about your
lighting for beginners tutorial you
dropped yesterday i think was amazing
i watched it last night and it's just
such a great if you guys don't know
anything about lighting and unreal
that's definitely one to check out um
and even if you do know a thing or two
about lighting and unreal
or trying to figure it out and get a
grasp on it he does a great job of just
like
making it really easy for everybody yeah
will you you're the one dude you're the
one
he says kudos for setting up the camera
early most important most often
overlooked step yeah because we gotta
see like
we're not making stuff for over there
we're making stuff for right here
all right let's see if we can't
get our lighting
kind of roped in here um exponential
height fog
yeah it's a foggy scene right
so
exponential height fog
is gonna be a big part of getting that
look um so
let's first things first we'll check on
this volumetric fog box
that just makes everything better
um and then we're going to crank this to
like point two or something
point three
all right we can crank this to one if we
want but that's a little much i think
point three is fine for now
um you notice that
these shadows are still sharp so we
wanna soften those things up there's a
couple different ways to do that many
many different ways to do that
um
one method that i
learned uh well actually yesterday from
from will foshay
is to do it with an hdri and that's
probably the fast
quick and fast way of doing it
the way i did this in my scene last week
was actually messing with i believe
the skylight
was it the skylight or was it
um
the sky atmosphere
yes it was the sky atmosphere
specifically the my scattering scale if
you crank this up i believe
it'll start to make it really overcast
that's a little bit much
um
there's a tutorial in the description
that i have linked to a guy that goes
over all this stuff he talks about
getting this overcast look it's also at
the end of willfox video his newest
video so i'll mess with the scattering
scale i also believe um we can take the
skylight
we can crank the intensity
intensity scale we can take that up a
little bit right um
this is stuff
that i'll kind of like rope this stuff
in once we have our stuff in place this
is good enough for now just to start
placing our different assets from
quixote now the first thing i want to do
is i'll hide this box you can hit g
to hide all the stuff
all right that we don't want to see
now
like i said qixel it's built in right
quicksilver bridge let me open this up
it's built in
to unreal engine
right so you have access to all of these
assets for free it is
some somehow they're they're doing this
i don't know how they're doing this for
free but it's a thing
um
and what i did is i basically looked at
my reference and i was like
okay
we're looking at some rocks we're
looking at some grass
and lucky for us they have
a tundra pack
we type tundra we go 3d assets
nature
yup yup yup
they got a lot of good stuff
that
really matches
the vibe right so if i hit this tundra
rock and
i think i can like
should be able to open these up
full screen anyway you all get the point
right we're trying to match
this vibe here
so it's just a matter of like scrolling
through here finding your assets that
work for you
and you can click on these related
collections so i'll click on the tundra
related pack and
it kind of has everything that matches
and goes with each other
in this thing
so you can see i went through and if you
hover over these assets you can hit the
little favorite button
and i'll go through all the ones that
look like they could work and i'll
favorite everything and for some reason
why it does favorites
is set to zero
oh it just needed to update
so throughout the week when i built this
right i favored all these assets ones
that i think would work together and all
you need to do
is download them right you can set the
quality
and i set it to nanite
and basically
nanite is allowing you
to have
you guys have heard to pitch millions
and millions of polygons millions and
millions of triangles
in your scene
um with little to no performance
effect right so you're able to just pile
on as much
stuff as possible and be able to fly
through your scene with a high frame
rate um so i'm selecting nanite for all
these you just hit download boom and
then add to your scene
and do that for all the stuff that you
think would work for whatever
environment you're trying to create
um
if you're trying to recreate the ones
that i'm doing right now i got the
tundra rocky ground we got
huge tundra rocky ground tundra rock
formation tundra rock formation two
tundra rocky ground two rocky ground
three right it just goes on and on
just a bunch of these tundra grounds and
then i'm using wild grass specifically
just this wild grass here and the blue
lupine that's it just these two i didn't
use the other ones
um
and i didn't even use this swampy ground
surface
material
right it's just these photo scans plus
these two pieces of grass and this
custom little totem that i made so with
that right you bring everything in it
makes a mega scans folder so we'll go to
3d assets and we have these different
assets that we can start placing right
so
the first thing that i see in my
reference is this totem is standing on
like a rocky
it's more rock than grass right
and it kind of trails off to the right
here so
first let me let me hop out of the
camera really quick
so if you right click the cine camera we
can stop piloting or actually if we
right click and pilot top left here you
can just click that and stop piloting
and let's um
let's just kind of place these assets
around our scene and see what we're
working with right so if you just drag
it out boom it's looking super nice
um and i'm gonna do that for the rest of
this stuff i think i had this guy kind
of like somewhere in the background
and we'll just go through and see what
we're working with this is a really nice
one it's half grass half rock i think
this would be good for like kind of a
foreground element
that we can later paint some grass onto
um
another deal like that yup yup yup
what else do we have more
rock yeah this is good stuff
very good stuff what else do we have to
work with this is a nice little
little piece there this stuff is awesome
really high quality
we'll work our lighting in
once we place all of our assets
i think we have some auto exposure going
with the camera as well so we'll need to
adjust and fine-tune that stuff later
okay that's the same deal
yeah this is really good really really
good stuff
really good stuff
this is the one yo this who's the one
son
this is the one that we're going to use
for the actual
totem that the totem will be standing on
get out
so i'm just gonna scooch all this mess
over to the side we're gonna get this
thing down
and
it's in place it's in place okay it's in
place
we're gonna fine tune it and then we
have one more this one i actually
grabbed uh
why does it look
weird it probably looks weird because
i messed with the material instance
so if we go to the material instance i
double click that right
and it looks like yes i did set all this
stuff up um i changed the saturation i
changed the albedo controls i believe
brightness just needs to come back to
one
contrast i think needs to be back to one
what
why is it
[Music]
roughness
specular roughness metallic contrast
brightness saturation
interesting i wonder why it's just
darkness oh i unchecked
no that doesn't make sense either
anyway i'm not gonna really work okay
it's back maybe it was loading who knows
not going to worry too much about that
right now
ctrl shift s will save everything
if you go file
save current level control s you know
but save all control shift s so i'm
constantly hitting ctrl shift s when i'm
doing this uh mto creations what's up if
ue5 landscape workflow is easier and
more versatile
than c4d is there still a benefit or
point to making them
in c4d
yeah actually um
you know i
that's a good question
because
you all know i've been using c4d for a
very long time
and i wanted to learn unreal engine i
knew that unreal engine was like a great
thing to learn
just from the awesome stuff that was
coming out of you know uh the epic games
and the quicksole uh
youtube channels and whatnot there's
just some really cool stuff being made
with it and it's in real time i'm like
oh i wanna i wanna get into that because
in my mind um
if i can get to like whatever's in my
head right the coolest thing that i see
in my head the the movie i see in my
head the the environment i see in my
head whatever if i can get that out of
me onto the computer
or onto a paintbrush whatever whatever
as quickly as possible as efficiently as
possible
that is where i want to be i just want
to be able to create
you know without any lag
from my brain to the computer screen and
i saw unreal engine as a way to do that
and it's all it's kind of a
real tough start for me
because it's a deep program
um but luckily nowadays there's
tutorials are coming out they're getting
real good william foshea shout outs yeah
that dude's the best
i'm trying to do some stuff you know
trying to make it easy for every
everybody make it uh make it fun for
everybody
um and then i'm like okay well yeah c4d
right so i gotta go back to c4d
and you know there there's a quality
difference between c4d and um
an unreal engine it kind of reminds me
of the days of using physical renderer
when like you had to type in all your
global illumination settings you had to
type in all of your bounce settings you
had to type in all of these render
settings and you're like constantly
moving back and forth between all these
different render settings to try and get
the most realistic look well
you know redshift
octane
arnold all those non-biased renders when
you hit render
it's just perfect it's real life
it takes a little bit longer um
you know cycles and eb i assume are the
same right it's i don't use blender but
i know that those are the renders that
blender uses when you hit render it just
looks nice
you don't really have to adjust settings
in unreal engine you have to adjust a
lot of settings unreal 5 makes it a lot
easier because of lumen
a lot of this stuff is happening behind
the scenes it's happening automatically
but we still have a lot
a lot more settings to like
balance
between to get that nice look so it is
nice to use c4d
you know or octane or redshift just a
renderer where it's non-biased and you
just hit render and it's looking good
um
but you know it's just a tool it's
another tool it is a deep conversation
that's a very deep conversation i can go
on and on let's get back to the art yeah
um
okay so we have we have some uh we got
some good stuff here let's hop back into
our camera and start placing these
things so right click pilot the camera
let's pull up our reference and kind of
see
what is going on here so i'm curious if
you select the photo and hit spacebar
it'll snap to the photo itself
right and i'm just going to
kind of like dock this
down here for you guys so we can get an
idea
of what's going on and what we need to
do okay so
first thing this totem
is
gonna be up here now if you're snapping
if these different things are snapping
right like
and you want to turn that off you want
to get more precise with it you're just
going to untoggle
these little options up here
this is grid snapping this is angle
snapping and scale snapping so now
you're free to move around
and this looks to me like
if we look at the reference
we're seeing we're kind of above it
right so we need to kind of lock in our
angle a little bit more
so once again right click and press e to
boom up
and
i want to kind of shape
this little pond area this this this
little like uh
this puddle area
with the back of this rock probably
something like i don't know something
like that looks good and i'll actually
scrunch oh
down on this thing
and we can bring our totem i'm hitting
spacebar to toggle between
position rotation and scale
and we'll just kind of
orbit this guy just a little bit like
that and that's generally okay like you
know we're gonna we're gonna rope things
in right we're gonna rope things in
um we have a nice little like
rocky horizon line so i can probably
grab
some of these guys
i can scrunch this down as well
you don't want to go too far with it but
um
just kind of work it in a little bit
this guy can come in and fill in this
area
just crunch them down a little bit
and we just want to fill in all this
this stuff here let's uh so we have this
lake that we gotta fill in
all right we can scale this down because
if we look at this puddle
it's like a little triangle boom a
little triangle tip and i think that's
why i grabbed this asset
is because it's shaped has a triangular
shape to it so i'm just going to scale
that down uniformly
and kind of move it over here we're
going to
populate and paint a bunch of shrubs
onto this in grass so it's not going to
be just that the rocky coal
um
what else what else we have some really
nice
grass in here in here we can bring this
guy in
we have this nice little rocky outline
that we can bring in over here
this can help populate and fill in the
area over here
this can prop hey you know this can
probably come in over here we can
probably duplicate
one of these guys holding alt will
duplicate for you
space bar to toggle between position
rotation and scale and i'm just gonna
i'm just gonna get that nice and nice
and nice you know
still in the cinema camera let's um
flip this around because it's kind of
like an embankment that goes up and i'm
going to scale it up
boom
now we're starting to get a thing this
floor you know what i'm saying we don't
even need it okay we don't need it and
i'm gonna show you guys about the water
here in a second
um because it's getting to be about that
time i'm going to
alt drag this
down i'm going to scale this up
and flatten it
not too much but just enough
because this is where
our water is going to go
and
you know we'll um
try and shape
let's see let's find like a nice little
outcropping some some grass
something like this
this has got uh
you can kind of rotate this around
to find a nice
little area here
and i just kind of want to shape this uh
this pond area
let's see
it kind of curves in and loops in and
connects right there so i think what i
can do
is
rotate this
to something like that
and we can even angle it just a touch
drop it down just a touch
so we get that natural kind of curve
right boom kind of curves around like
that
and we can even rotate this a little bit
more this is like the fine tune right
fine tuning it just touch
and maybe
maybe
cuz i don't want this giant boulder
anyway either
something like this
something like this yeah um there might
be an area over here that needs to be
filled in so i'll duplicate this guy
holding alt
get this in
boom
i'll flip it
something like that
this is not half bad
not half bad yeah
okay
so based off the reference right
it looks flat here and it kind of curves
up just a little bit up to this area
right so
i think what i'll do
we we almost don't need this
i'm going to delete it
this bit
you see what kind of comes up here is a
little lip well maybe maybe what we can
do is just angle it
like that
drop this down
yeah that feels that feels pretty good
let's rotate this guy
yes we want more of the grass
so that's feeling a little bit better to
me
[Music]
and we'll drop it down we'll scoot it
over
something like that looks pretty good to
me okay
so just already with the lighting
that we worked in
uh and it's just a quick sketch we just
quickly sketched the lighting in
um but we've placed our camera we've
placed our assets mainly at this point
um the next thing let's get the water in
here because the water is a new thing
that came out later in 4 2 7 ah who
knows
um and it's still a thing in
ue5 of course
so let's talk about the water i'm
quickly going to select all of this
geo and put it in the
geometry folder
cool cool
um it's looking a little bright i'm
going to
in our let's see in our post process if
we type brightness
we check min and max brightness and set
this to 1.
you can also set this to like oh let's
try two
1.5 maybe
cool that way it's our it's locked we're
not having any auto exposure going on
and we can
return to
to the lighting here in a second
but let's see if we can't get
some water popping off all right so i'm
gonna stop piloting
no i'm gonna stop piloting this top left
we can click that bam
all right
awesome awesome awesome yeah there's
some holes but it's fine you can't see
them
um now water works
with
landscapes okay so let me try and
remember this is the first thing i did
earlier this week i think the first
thing you got to do actually we got to
go to plugins
type
water and you check these two
you'll have to restart your engine but
you have to check these in order to get
the water and i believe if you just type
water up here then you have all your
water stuff right so
i was messing with the lake
and if you try and drag out a lake
it's not gonna do anything because it
needs a
uh
the landscape
to live on essentially right so i'm
gonna make a landscape
top left right select mode if we go to
landscape or shift f2
we're going to create a landscape or
essentially just a floor or a grid
for
landscape stuff to happen on this is way
too big we don't need this much so
i'm gonna take
the
i'm gonna make this seven by seven
number of components
we could probably just do four by four
we really don't need
that much this is plenty okay um and i'm
going to create this okay
now we can paint
a bunch of different hills and stuff but
we don't need it for that really i'm
gonna undo that
we just need it for
the water because the water is going to
populate this right so
um
let's go ahead and go back to select
mode
okay
and
let's grab that landscape
and i'm going to reset the psr
that brings it like over here all right
okay
basically like that is all we really
need
right
and we can probably raise it up a little
bit
[Music]
we'll get there we'll get there okay
let's just get some water so with water
selected um or typed in on the place
actors window we're gonna grab that body
that lake body and boom
look at that and i think we can hide the
landscape at this point and it's just
it's water yo this is some water okay
and it doesn't look good
it doesn't look good
we gotta make it look
like this
you know
this is very different looking water
smaller ripples
no there's no waves
it's more of a still kind of situation
right so
let's see what we can do
you're gonna control your water from
two
places mainly and let me see if i can
remember what the heck is going on i
might need to hop back into my other
scene to see what's good with it um but
first
right up in here if we
scroll down with the water body lake
selected okay and we scroll down
to wave
uh we're gonna have some options
and i think the first thing we need to
mess with
is the wa is the wave source and right
now it's set to water waves asset
reference but if we set it to
gerstner waves
and then we drop down this waves box and
we drop down this wave waves box
we can unravel all of these settings
here and mess with the waves okay so
right now these things are
going ham okay
uh let's try and just have it be still
let's get it to stillness and then we'll
start working in some motion so let's
mess with these settings and see what we
can do right
number of waves what happens if we
change number of waves let's try it 200.
whoa okay we are in some sort
of bubble dimension
is not cool let's set this to one
and see what what happens if we set it
to one
all right
closer closer closer
they're a bit more still not as many
waves but we still got
some rolly rolly roll in here that we
want to get rid of um
what can we do what can we do minimum
wavelength zero
okay i did nothing maximum wavelength
zero
disappeared what if we set max wavelet
to one because we need something
okay
okay it's coming back to me now let's
try 20. let's try
20.
all right so we have a bunch of like
really steep waves that are rolling in
this direction let's talk about
direction really quick while we can tell
what's going on
um direction bam
we can change the direction of the waves
see which way they're going we kind of
want them
coming towards camera
because in the reference the water was
kind of blowing towards camera
but it's really intense i think it's the
amplitude that's killing us max
amplitude is too much we just let's try
point two
ah so much better
so much better okay
guys we're we're doing something we're
getting there
um let's take the floor let's drop it
down let's maybe take this bit and give
it some
a little bit more thickness
let's take this and
maybe give it some more thickness just a
little bit we want to go too much with
it
and maybe we angle it
a little bit like that
something like this
cool we can take the floor
and and maybe just bring it up a little
bit
this guy we can probably drop down a
touch
there we go
yeah we're starting to get a little
something this is much better much
closer to what we're going for so let's
talk about the direction and the ripples
and all that good stuff right so
direction angular spread that's gonna
kind of break up the water um if i set
that to zero
wow it looks like nothing happened but
if i crank it
to 3000
looks like nothing happened so
most of my time throughout the week
creating this art was basically
messing with the water settings
so many water settings okay
um or not so many it's more just
fine tuning finagling these things to
like get the look you want and i still
wasn't quite happy with the look i want
the reflections aren't quite right
either we're in lumen right now um also
let's note here that
this water
right is you know it's it's it's kind of
weird looking um
which brings me to
the water settings
let's talk about those so we have
right we dropped the lake on the
landscape and we have these points and
we can bring these points in
to just kind of be the area that we want
so
that's what i'm gonna do
i'm gonna hit these points bam
amazing amazing amazing now we just have
the area that we need
and we should be able to just
move this
this works yeah it's totally fine
uh if you select something and hit f
boom you'll snap to it and we'll hit g
to get rid of all these icons right so
now we don't have any water
chilling outside of the area that
you know that we need it
and of course we still have our camera
or cine camera to hop into
and this is what our look is gonna be
like okay
um
okay so we kind of have everything like
ball parked in at this point we have our
water ball parked we have our lighting
ball parked um we have
our our like terrain
more i'd say more than ball parked in
um it's really lighting and water at
this point the only thing that we
need to add
would be our shrubs and to paint our
shrubs in so
i'm just gonna grab some kombucha really
quick
not sponsored by the way but this is my
favorite brand gotta say gts
pops off
um
and then we're gonna
we're gonna get some shrubs in here okay
and then we'll fine tune our water
we'll fine tune our lighting we'll make
things look nice yeah
[Music]
big dutch
asking if i'd use fresnel to
have the water look a bit more realistic
one thing i think the biggest thing to
have the water look more realistic is to
change our reflection method so if i go
to my post process volume
and i type reflection
and the method right now is lumen but if
i change it to say screen space
we're going to see
you know
that totem or that monument
right up in there in that reflection
which is kind of what it should be doing
or you can go raytraced and have it look
really nice
and that's what i did my final render in
was ray traced so
once again i'll show you guys
what this looks like
final
boom so that's ray traced water
um i tweak the settings we're going to
do that we're going to tweak the
settings we're going to get these shrubs
in here there's wind if you notice the
wind here
is looking really nice so that's an easy
check box
and our lighting looks a little bit
different so we'll go over that and
obviously our little pillar is textured
got some camera shake that's done in
after effects i have some film grain
that's done in after effects vignette
after effects but you can do it in
unreal and i'll show you how to get that
because it does help the vibe it helps
kind of like
once again rope it in we're not we're
not
we're like 50 there at this point
so let's um
i'll leave it to you guys do you guys
want to tweak water do you guys want to
lay down the bushes and the shrubs or do
you want to
do
the lighting to get the lighting right
what does the chat say
christopher i appreciate that man thank
you
i'm glad to be here as well
all right tyron says lighting tweaked
the water we got lighting we got bushes
we got shrubs we got lightning we got
this is tough
lighting
light and fog lighting lighting
lighting water water lighting everything
it's all going to happen no matter what
let's get the fog let's do some lighting
and then we'll hit the uh with the water
so lighting wise
so far what we've done a recap in the we
have exponential height fog popping off
that density is doing its thing point
three you can break
the slider and go beyond right so like
if you try and crank it it's going to go
to 0.05
but if you type in a value say 10
you know it can go beyond
so
i'll crank it up to like point five
another big note here is this volumetric
fog box is checked and that is very
important
um we have a skylight
where we took the intensity scale to two
all right so it was at one
i bumped it to two
and you see how in the reference the
it's more milky kind of lighting um this
is looking kind of
blah
right now um
i think i need to diffuse the light more
so
so in our directional light we can
let's see let's see let's see
i'm gonna take the temperature and
actually
warm it up
just a touch i know fog and stuff goes
cool but i
the reference image is a bit more warm
we're still getting a kind of a direct
sunlight look
if i go to my sky atmosphere
and again we scroll down to the
atmosphere my the my scattering scale if
i reset that to default
um it's looking like direct sunlight but
if we crank the my scattering scale to
like
two it's really going to get that
overcast look but i think this is too
much it's too bland in my opinion so
maybe we try setting it to one
maybe we try setting it to 0.5
um
0.75
and messing with that that could help um
the scattering scale could help too so
0.03 let's try like 0.2
oh okay so what that's doing is that's
like um
i have a tutorial link below
and that is like pull air pollution if
we take that to like five it's gonna
turn into like
some freaking mars level stuff
but we don't really want that
i'm gonna reset that to how it was
continuing down the list my scattering
absorption scale let's try point two
point five
one and i just kind of push these values
really like zero what does this arrow
look like
i reset it it was at 0.004 the
anisotropy 0.8 let's set that to one
zero and it's just me messing i'm just
really messing with these different
values and i actually like
we have exponential distribution as well
so that that's doing a lot to actually
smooth it out i like that okay so
exponential distribution can go up to
point er to two
that's looking better um
but it still looks a little washed
out
and the shadows are just
looking a little
i know what it is i know what it is okay
so the scattering scale we can go back
to like point
point three
point four
point five
okay
and
i think it's our skylight perhaps
the intensity
on the skylight the intensity scale so
if we set that to 0.5
okay it's going to be a little darker
now which is looking
a little bit better but it's still
not quite there
let's go 1
1.5
let me try a different method let's try
um
[Music]
let's try
doing this with an hdri just just to
experiment so settings plugins you're
going to type hdri
check that restart your engine and then
when you go to lighting
boom uh where's it lights bam you'll
have your hdr backdrop and we drop that
in
and drop it down
we don't want
that that background
we definitely don't want that background
and i'm wondering
so the exponential height fog
is kind of covering it but not really so
i think there's another way to do it
like if we go to
our if i turn off
where are you hdr backdrop we turn that
off if we go to our skylight
i think we can load a cube map
should be able to load i'm not exactly
sure
the way to do this um and i know will
focus talked about it in his
tutorial on
lighting yesterday
i wish i knew
i wish i knew
uh well anyway those are options
i'm just gonna keep tweaking i'm gonna
keep doing it the way i had i had it
going um your source soft angle on your
sunlight um i believe if we adjust this
it'll soften out
the shadows a little bit if i set it to
like 100
that does a pretty nice job of softening
those shadows and i'm also gonna take
this rock
i'm gonna boost it up a little bit and
drop it down
yeah
alwyn alwyn
my dude um my chance of failure is
absolute zero you know i remember you
saying that last time and that that did
a lot for me because you know you're
kind of right
it is absolute zero
because no matter what i do i'm doing
something
okay um
exponential height fog maybe we need to
do um
secondary fog we can do some secondary
fog that'll pop some stuff off just a
little bit but we don't need too much of
it zero i'm just messing with stuff at
this point guys
um
directional in scattering you set that
to zero
it was at four by default set it to 100
it's not really doing much for us okay
okay
g
b dude gamer god
godrays you want god rays love the
content from canada where from canada i
love me some canada
this technically
was taken in canada
newfoundland right is newfoundland
canada it's up there
um
god rays
see the thing is though god raise is not
really a thing in this you know this
we're going for overcast you know god
raised up in here
skylight okay i'm just kind of going
through here volumetric clouds sky
atmosphere
um
atmospheric height i'm gonna set that to
oh okay so that's doing some stuff
it was at 60 by default if we take it to
the difference between five and sixty is
a thing
and i kind of like five a little bit
better
um i need to mess with these my
settings
exponential distribution
i think the sky just needs to be
brighter but the thing is when i boost
this skylight
it just like
i set that to 10
yeah that's obviously way too much
um could it be the sky atmosphere see
that looks better i think it's the sky
atmosphere
that's graying it up like that um sky
luminance factor aerial perspective
21 okay okay
oh that is great
height fog contribution okay so back at
default it's one let's try setting it to
three
yes okay
five
yes much better
much better
i'll i'll do it at uh
at five
and i'm just messing i am just messing
here this is the art direction tab
and certainly help me art direct it
maybe even six
all right and then let's do some
vignetting so in our post process volume
if we type in vignette
and
we turn on the intensity
we can
really work this vignette in because in
the photo
there's some vignetting going on here
there's definitely some vignetting going
on
so
in the post process volume once again
we're gonna get some vignetting
and let's go back to our exponential
height fog
and
maybe set it to 0.4
if we set it to 0.2
0.4.35 perhaps
is looking
pretty
pretty
nice
all right so one thing i can do is also
bring down the brightness of these uh
these assets so
we're still talking about lighting we're
gonna hop over to the water in a second
this is looking a little bright so what
we'll do is we'll select the asset we'll
double click this rocky ground tundra
and we'll set the brightness down to
like 0.5 i'm just going to move this off
screen
so you guys can kind of see what is
happening
bear with me
okay here we go so brightness was at 1
if we set the brightness to
0.5
why is it
yeah we should be doing something
oh it's the wrong asset
that's why
that's why so with the asset selected
on the right here you'll see materials
we can hit this folder with the
magnifying glass it's gonna find it for
us then we can double click it and
that's now the right one so brightness
we could bring that down to like
right that's zero obviously we don't
want that
0.5 contrast is one so i'm just kind of
adjusting it
to get a better look
the water is looking a little green
it's looking a little washed out
let's see
post process let's try some saturation
uh global saturation we can try 1.2
yeah that's looking a little bit better
and in the post process volume if i type
in reflections
oh we're still doing ray trace let's
switch back to lumen
that that's looks yeah okay so switching
between raytraced and lumen i was in ray
trace that whole time
right so it kind of a different look
here
when you're in lumen and i like working
in lumen
because everything just looks really
nice we can switch back to ray tracing
later as well
um
i think these rocks are looking a little
spicy
so what we can do
is select that asset make sure we're not
searching for anything we can find the
material here bam double click it
and
you know one thing i like to do
is mess with the reflection or the
specular and the roughness to get more
of that catch light bouncing off the
rock and it's really spicy right now
so we can kind of scroll down to
the max roughness and by default i
believe it's set to one
but
i think we need a little something
because it i want it to feel
like wet rock bass specular is at 0.5
right now if we set that to zero it's
not going to reflect anything
we set it to one
you know it's gonna
reflect
one's worth
point five is point five's worth
and the roughness basically smooths out
it makes it more matte so if i set it to
one that's like super matte right
like uh the back of my phone case or
something
or the top of uh like a macbook super
matte right
still reflective but matt if we set it
to zero it's like
a mirror almost
you can see a reflection in it
so we'll find a balance somewhere
0.35 maybe
yeah that's not bad that's not bad and
you can do that for each one of these
rocks and that's like a big
big thing that i do here
is i'm going through and
picking
different
materials and kind of just be like okay
does this need to catch more light
you can mess with the brightness the
contrast
that helps that certainly helps
and this was all adjusted based off of
my previous scene
i'm gonna come in here and just kind of
like reset these back to
to default yeah that one's default
i think it could use a bit more like if
we just crank the saturation
what does that do for us okay a little
something
i i want
more green we need more green
and i think that's gonna help with the
shrubs you know what i'm saying so
um
let's
let's add some shrubs and then we can
keep fine-tuning keep fine-tuning keep
fine-tuning yeah
so
we're gonna get back to the water as
well
but let's go ahead and control shift s
save all
and work in some shrubs all right so
same deal guys i went to this little top
left this box up here right
i went to quixle bridge
and
i favorited some stuff but if you go
home and you go to 3d plants
you can find whatever 3d plants you want
i've already favorited some
and specifically i'm using the blue
lupine and some wild grass okay
and if you download it i'm going for the
high quality right so you hit download
and you add it to your scene and it'll
automatically pop into your scene
so under mega scans we got 3d plants
and let's start with the wild grass okay
so we have a bunch of
different pieces of wild grass you can
see automatically they're animated
with wind and everything it's so
freaking cool
all right but we don't want to we don't
want to plant like plant these one by
one that's gonna take
far too long so
i'm gonna undo this
and let's just let's do it the right way
shall we um because we have a lot of
grass we gotta place in order to fill
this out okay
so
how do we do that well if we go to the
top left select mode right and we go to
foliage or shift f3
that's going to bring us to our foliage
painter
kind of layout right and
it's asking us to drop foliage into here
i think you can probably click this and
add stuff
if i type wild grass
wild underscore grass i can
select the ones i want or i can just
drag and drop these guys and i think
that's what i'll do so
i want to make sure i'm getting
there's no right and wrong wild grass
but
we double click this
that's like dead
dead grass
for sure these should all be loading i
think these are more dead so i'm gonna
go for the ones that are live
these guys yeah so
let's drag
all of these bam anything is a static
mesh i'm just going to drag them up into
here and by default they're checked on
right so that means when i'm up in here
with the brush
right i have it set to single instance
mode i don't want that i want to uncheck
single instance mode and i just want to
paint
shrubs everywhere
everywhere no i don't want to do that
because that looks like that looks like
butt i'll undo that um
but you notice that hey it works
it totally works they're just big right
they're a little big so what i'll do
is i'll select all of these guys and you
can see bam automatically this dialog
tree came up or this menu tree right
i'll shift click everything
and scroll down to touch
we can
um oh you guys can't see this let's get
let's get my big old head out of here
for a second
so
thank you soto
thank you soto cheers i feel like soda
needs a mic so he can say what's up
everybody
but he says hello
um
so
the scale right bam
set to one cool
we want to chill these out so like 0.5
if we set them both to 0.5 that means
we're only getting 0.5 scale graphs and
that looks a lot better
but let's do something between like
0.35 and 0.65 that way there's a bit of
scale variation in our graphs i think
it'll make it look a bit more realistic
and what i'm going to do is just come in
here
based off my reference which i'll have
on the screen to my right
and i'm going to start painting grass
where i think grass needs to be okay
so definitely on this embankment here
we'll have some grass
i'll leave that rock there
boom it's looking good and we can change
the density if you guys want to change
the density as well but i think
i think it's fine for now
just get up in there
back in here it's looking good i think
it's still a little big actually so i'm
going to take the max
0.5 no matter what and then uh 0.3 for
the min
so anywhere between 0.3 and 0.5 is going
to give me some scale variation
sweet yeah get back here
so that's looking good and then i
definitely want some foreground
dealies
up in here
um
some shrubs here because they you know
they're growing by the water they feed
off the water they live off the water
so they're gonna be by the water you
know what i'm saying
bam looking good we're gonna just
kind of get up in here a little bit
scatter them it doesn't need to be thick
just sprinkling these guys
back here i think could use some it's a
little
i don't like that
super saturated green so we can get
those guys
popping off i'm gonna leave the rock
silhouette as the rock silhouette
we can get them up in here too
we can have some shrubs growing up in
here
in the water probably we'll have some
little water buds
don't like those though
and shift i believe will erase yeah
shift erases
very good to know we'll get some little
buds back here
not on top but just back in here
kind of back in here as well
and i'll get a little silhouettes i
think some silhouettes back here are
justified
just popping up over the horizon a
little bit right
maybe one there
this little guy back there this little
guy
okay
not bad
not too
shabby
at all
boom
maybe a little bit more in here
and you notice i'm not i'm not going out
and like trying to do all this
it's literally just our view right here
this is all we want is this view right
here
maybe i can touch a little bit here
because our camera sometimes will sneak
over
just a little bit give us a little bit
more
something like that i think the water is
actually not looking too great right now
it's hurting our
image um
so we'll get to that in a second i'm
going to place a couple more shrubs
though because we want some variation so
that's where that blue lupine one i was
talking about um yeah blue lupine
now this one i don't want to scatter i
don't want to just chunk them all in
right so i'm gonna select all these i'm
gonna delete them
actually no i am not gonna do that
i will select them all and uncheck them
and then i'm gonna drag these blue
lupins
in
and they should be deep by default
checked on yes
so i'm gonna select all of these
and i want the scale let's um
do a test okay they're massive so we're
gonna do 0.3 to 0.5
and that's a little bit more in the
range of what we're going for okay so
we're going to undo that yeah
now i want to do single instance mesh
mode so i'm just going to or single
instance mode i'm going to check that
box and it's going to
cycle
um
so all selected or cycle through
selected um
it's basically like the same thing all
selected it's gonna go through
all these
and give you a different one every time
it should
are those the same
it's hard to tell it's kind of hard to
tell
cycle through selected
yeah those are different
cool
so i'm just going to go through base
again based off of my reference
i'm going to go through and start
placing these guys so there's some here
on the left there's some here right in
the foreground there's some on the right
there's some in the back they're just
sprinkled around a little bit so
i'm gonna go ahead and uh
and start sprinkling these mugs let's do
um definitely one up here in the
foreground
and i have to click a couple times
because i think
scale wise let's actually beef the scale
0.5 and 0.6
0.7
yikes okay
0.5 was right i think i just need to
deselect the smaller ones
so we'll just keep these big more bigger
ones
there we go there we go much better much
better
awesome and we'll just kind of
paint these guys in
they're a little big
still a little big
so we'll take that down to 0.4
i'll check these guys on too just
because
a little bit
of variation is good
and just kind of populate
this area back in here as well
and shift will delete if you guys don't
like what's going on there's a lot back
here i think i went a little a little
heavy on that side
but that is not bad that's not too
shabby
sweet
and you can go to town you can throw in
whatever you want any sort of variation
um
i think the biggest offender at this
point is the
the water but before we get to that
let's just pop a quick material on this
totem so if i
come up to this thing
and remember right
we set our
our focus settings earlier on
so we're always looking at this this is
the focus of the image right
so let's do same deal guys same deal
let's go back to select mode right so
we're back in as normal if we go to
qixel bridge we can look for now
go home we can look for surfaces
and we can find a metal a rusted metal
somewhere in here metal
um
corroded
yeah something in here i think i
selected one i already favorited it
favorited favorited it that's hard to
say
i didn't
but i know it's in my scene
because i used it my previous one all
right so
if we go to surfaces
and we bust out rusty metal it's either
this one it's definitely this one look
at that
it's beautiful already
it's by default it's looking great
we'll come back here
post up
and work on our water
you can also work on our fog a little
bit too
center it up nice okay so the water yeah
the water's the hardest part i talked
about like
these settings here right the uh
the number of waves the minimum
wavelength
etc etc
and we can
talk about how the water moves and then
we can also talk about how the water
looks and they kind of go hand in hand
but let's see if we can't mess with the
setting the water settings um to get a
more realistic look so
i'm gonna select the water body lake and
try and find the material that it's
using if we scroll down we can find
under rendering the water material we're
going to hit that browse button browse
to
and it'll pop us right up in here we
have this material instance for the
water okay
so
[Music]
let's see what's the best way to do this
yeah i'll just have it off to the right
i guess
so default water
default distant water speed if we set
that to zero it's just gonna
do exactly the same thing okay
negative
one all right so that's that's changing
some stuff
um
default distant normal like i just went
through all these settings just to mess
with stuff and see what happened
default distant water skill oh here we
have near
water scale and this is definitely near
water
default distant default near water scale
512 what if we set that to zero
well we set that to 2 000
i think default is probably fine
i don't know why it's not updating
is it not updating
there we go
um all this stuff i think what we need
is the global
parameter or not no not global
parameters we have
somewhere here
here we go water shading
so
i have messed with this water
so much
to get this kind of look um you have
albedo right so that's going to change
the color of your water
i think it might be a little saturated
in our case so we can desaturate it
maybe darken it up a little bit
so that could help we have
water fresnel roughness okay so point
one
zero and one all right so that's gonna
make your water like
i don't know whatever
whatever that look is
uh we have metallic
and metallic
i was using that to catch a bit more of
the reflection but this this doesn't
look bad certainly does not look bad
i think it's moving a little too fast
and
this setting default distant water speed
if i type in speed
yeah it looks like this is the only
option for speed and i don't know why if
i hit
okay that's better
that's certainly better
it's more chill these plants i know are
moving right you're not really seeing
them in the viewport because
you're getting a kind of a blurry
view
of this motion what you're seeing here
it's kind of difficult to tell but it's
blurry it's just blurry if i were to
select one of these plants
um we'll get back to the water in a
second i am a scatter brain person so um
if i select one of these plants right
and we talk about wind for a second
um
let's
try and find the plant i know it was
where are you
mega scans plants blue lupine
okay if we pull up blue lupin
material the material instance okay and
we scroll down you have this check box
for enable grass wind and by default
it's turned off
um but if we take like the wind height
to like two
it's going crazy
you can kind of see how it's like doing
this weird blurry
morph into what looks like a wind effect
and it doesn't look right wind intensity
let's go back to like
you're kind of losing it you're just
losing it entirely
but know that when you render this out
with anti-aliasing
you're going to get a much
cleaner looking wind and i'll show you
once again
there is none of that weird blurriness
right here you know
it looks nice and crisp and that's
because anti-aliasing is checked on with
64 samples
this is also a ray traced scene and
we'll kind of toggle over that
at the end of the stream here
right so
that that that's that's crazy that's
going buck wild okay
that's too intense um but i just wanted
you guys to know that that when you
render this out it's gonna look better
it's not gonna look blurry like that
i'd say the biggest thing i did for
lighting um with the water and it was d
it was like
at least the full day of just tweaking
water settings um water body lake right
if i have it selected and i scroll down
here to these different waves settings i
was just messing with this
constantly messing with this
alright so that looks horrible i'm going
to set the steepness
of these waves to zero
amplitude fall off like all of this
stuff does stuff it's just very um
set that to zero there we go okay so
that's more of like a still lake
200 waves is way too much though
20 all right that looks more
that looks like something but not right
two
go one now the wavelength when you crank
this wavelength up
it looks a lot more still now
because the waves are a lot they're just
coming uh
they're bigger the wavelengths are the
waves are larger
but the the smaller you get the
wavelength down
the more of the ripples you'll actually
see and the number of waves it'll start
to make it look like almost like an
anisotropic effect where you have so
much noise
so much small long stretched out noise
that just doesn't look good so
it's really like balancing between these
two settings here
to find the best setting
and the best look for what you're going
for number of waves set to one is
probably the way to go for me at least
and then
that's not bad
that's certainly not bad now if we go
and set this to a ray trace
look so post-processing volume
reflections
from lumen to ray traced
i think the water just looks a lot
better to be honest with you guys
um it's deeper
um
you actually catch the reflections
a lot better here
so my render my final render was with
this ray trace lighting
i think it looks really nice
um we can
retrace the lighting mode we can oh hit
lighting for reflections that is
actually a setting
that makes when you're in lumen it makes
it look a lot better so if we go to
project default
upgrading to hit lighting for
reflections and if you just hover over
the stuff it'll tell you what it does
gives this method gives the highest
reflection quality but greatly increases
gpu cost as the material needs to be
evaluated and shadow rays traced
so boom and then you can
update the lighting quality you can
crank it up but still i find it going to
just raytrace looks the best um and then
we have rave traced reflection settings
all right so samples per pixel if we
crank this up to like 32 it's going to
chug
but it's going to look better now i'm
going to show you at the end of the
stream here once we get to this point
how to
export the highest settings
um
because you don't have to
crank this if i go to uh
what is it a little burger up here top
left and i go to show fps
we can see we're running at 8 fps
you don't have to crank your your
highest settings in this little viewport
view i'm going to set that back to one
but we can do you can use console
commands later um through the movie
render queue
to just export the highest settings
we're previewing it on
you know still settings that look nice
but
we want to export the highest quality
right
so now that we've switched over to ray
tracing i'm just going to
grab this rock here
and bring down
the or crank the roughness a little bit
because it's it's a little bright
um
so we can go like 0.5
just to chill it out a little bit
0.6
that looks better
that looks better
yeah and the more you can go back and
forth between
the actual
reference and your art the better
most certainly
but this is looking pretty darn good
guys this is looking pretty good i'm
trying to think if there's any other
like
things we should talk about um
because i'm probably going to
do like i'd love to export this and show
you
what i'm doing in after effects to to
bring it to the max but
let's try our post-process volume i'm
gonna show you guys grain real quick if
you type in grain we can check film
grain intensity and just you know
yeah it's on
set it to 1 set it to 0.5 you can get a
nice little subtle grain effect going on
here which looks really nice
um but i do this in in after effects
afterwards but you can certainly do it
there and same for vignette right like
i'm gonna do my vignette in in after
effects as well but you can have some
vignette popping off here that looks
really nice
um
what else what else
do we need to talk about we talked about
wind
we talked about some of the water
settings
um we
talked about painting the foliage
the fog maybe i'll touch the fog up just
a little bit more before we render this
thing
um so under lighting exponential height
fog we can maybe go like i don't know
point
four
zero is obviously
not what we want we want some fog in
here
hmm
we have some secondary fog
direct directional in scattering i
remember that was not doing anything
scattering distribution 0.2 we can try
0.5 we can try zero i always
like to max out my numbers
to see what happens
i try and get the most extreme effect
first and then go for
the subtle
extinction scale
okay okay okay so this is like
fog is coming closer to us
ah
okay this actually looks
let's see
not bad 0.5 that way we bring some of
the
yeah we bring back some of the shadows
but based on the reference i'm looking
at the
the values here this totem is a little
brighter
and it's
there's definitely something diffusion
going on which we can do in after
effects so maybe i just i leave that at
one but it's good to know we have that
there
1.5 maybe
one
yeah that's not bad
view distance
[Music]
yeah we definitely want that i think how
it was
static lighting
scatter intensity
20 ah okay so zero
and
five no
zero and two
one by default i think default is good
[Music]
oh epoxo thank you bloom yeah so bloom
that's another thing in the post process
volume bloom
thank you thank you sir so we can check
the
method on we can check the intensity on
and we can check the threshold on okay
so if we
keep the method at standard i know
convolution is a thing that's apparently
like
more accurate
for cinematic uh then it's expensive for
games is what it says but we are here
for the cinematic experience so
i'm gonna leave it to convolution i'ma
crank it
nothing is happening
because i think there's a weird thing
where like you have to do it in standard
and then go to convolution and it's
still not working i don't know why
that is the case so i'm gonna go back to
standard
so we crank the bloom but then the
threshold is what determines
what
is blooming the brightest part is it
your whole image or is it just the
brighter parts of your image so the
threshold will determine that
um 0.5 i think is
you see a little bit of that yep
we can try point
three
and kind of get a little bit more which
is looking nice we can try point two
even
that's getting a little something and i
think that helps a lot papaxo that's
good stuff man thank you
and let's see if we can't make
the shadows the highlights and the
shadows of this water
more contrasty and this is something
that i did in post but i'm wondering if
i can do it here inside of unreal engine
hmm
okay
so i'm gonna go to
the water material by selecting the
water scrolling down and grabbing the
water material searching for it and then
double clicking it and popping back in
here
let's see if we can't mess with this
to give us uh
kind of what we're going for metallic
we set metallic to one
ah it's not quite
it's not quite doing it um
we can set the fernell roughness to one
i don't like that it makes the water
look like foggy
and i hate that our sun is here i'm
gonna actually adjust the sun a little
bit
and see if we can't get a better uh a
better setup water roughness
yeah i feel like the water doesn't need
to be rough
it needs to be crisp sharp reflections
and the specular
of course
is doing nothing okay
let's see about angling our sun
our directional light and see
what happens so if i hit g
it'll bring up art oh my god it'll bring
up icons
let's get that thing out of the way
let's get this thing out of the way
where's our sun at
where you at son directional light
get down here
and let's rotate this mug
okay so the sun is doing a great job of
like actually brightening up the sky
for us
which we want
and the question is like is it noon
is it sunset
i don't like
the sun reflection in the water
so i'll probably do something like that
uh-huh
and i think it needs to be a bit more
overcast so i'm going to go to
the sky atmosphere
hit the my scattering scale
it's at 0.5 this is zero let's try 0.6
yeah that's a bit more overcast i like
that a little bit better
[Music]
boom
a secondary can we add a secondary noise
to the water i'm not quite sure i'm sure
we can let me show you how confusing
this is
um so if we go to the material instance
we pull it up and we want to go to the
master material let's
go to the parent
this is the parent okay so we'll go in
here
and then the parent of that is the water
material which is all this stuff
which is actually not
too crazy
so we have our waves this is what makes
our waves it's crazy this is this is
deep this is deep for sure
um
we got our normal maps we got our basic
water shading
which looks like material functions
which yeah this gets deep so it gets
deep and deep and deep and deep and
i'm sure if i was a mad scientist i can
get up in there but you know there's
only so much i can do
only so much i can do let me let me
render a version for you guys so
you can see what i'm doing in after
effects um
sure you could do a lot of it here in
unreal engine like we can go to the post
process volume and we can work in the
color correction
if i type
color
and we hit the global settings
global gamma
let's like drop that to like point eight
already looks so much better
yo already looks so much better doesn't
it
um
we can hit some
shadows we can drop the shadow
uh offset isn't gonna do much for us
that looks like booty
um
that looks way better
dropping the gamma always looks nice um
i found that like
i would rather have my like super
atmospheric photography looking a little
bit more underexposed than overexposed i
think a darker dimmer image is just
simply moodier
and i think dropping dropping the gamma
like that helps a ton i forgot i did
that in my last scene
so that looks much better in my opinion
oh let's set up uh depth of field
yes so under our camera okay
um let's close this out and let's find
the lens settings okay so lens settings
our f-stop is 1.2 but we're not really
getting too much depth of field
if i try to take that to like point two
um
oh i'm sorry i'm doing the wrong i'm
doing the right thing
but i accidentally did the right thing
first i was trying to do the wrong thing
first to show you the difference let's
just change that back to 1.2
because those are our lens settings if
we go to our
focal length right we can do our focal
length
right i have that set to 25
our current aperture that's what we want
to change
if we drop that to say 1.2 we're going
to get a little bit
nicer depth of field but let's say i
want to go like 0.5 and just break it
it's not going to go below
1.12 and that's because in our lens
settings
the minimum f-stop is 1.12 if i set it
to 0.5
or just as a hero
um let me do what i want you know what
i'm saying
no restraints let's go 0.9
and let's try 0.2 it's gonna look that
looks bad for sure and it starts
breaking at a certain point
but
if i go to like 1.2
maybe
0.8
it's going to match my film photo a
little bit more
right it's blurry
even this is blurry and that's something
we want to talk about in after effects
we're gonna do that it's not crisp and
clean
right
um
but i i think 1.2 is probably fine um
but let's let's let's try and render
this thing so i can show you guys what's
up
uh
current aperture 1.2
is good
okay i'm liking this let me take off the
bloom let me take off the vignette let
me take off the grain okay so that's all
in our post process volume
bloom
where you at
be gone okay
you're chilling and you're cool i dig it
but we're gonna get you later all right
green
a necessity but we're gonna do we're
gonna do
right
vignette
all right same we're gonna get you big
difference right big difference
but we're gonna get you later okay we're
setting up for render
get you looking nice okay
um
so
what we will do
is
um in order to render this
we we can go up here and we can
click on high resolution screenshot and
we can
set the multiplier to two so it renders
two times the resolution but scales it
back down to our current resolution or
no does it scale it i don't think it
does it just makes it bigger and better
we'll go there
and we'll find
boom
this is what we just rendered out
okay so you can do it like that
or we want to do a movie we're here to
make movies right so
what i will do is we want to
do this through the movie render queue
all right
and in order to do that
we need a level sequence
we essentially have to have a timeline
it has to know how many frames
we're working with all right
so if we go
in our content browser right we just go
to content i've done this before but i'm
gonna do it again with y'all
if we right click
up in here
and we go to
animation
level sequence we're going to make a
level sequence all right
that's essentially a timeline and we're
going to hop into our timeline
which is 150 frames with nothing in it
just like in da vinci just like in
premiere
just like in after effects you you know
you got to have something in your in
your in your timeline we have nothing
right now
so we need to bring our camera in it
needs to know what angle do we want to
render from so we just drag our camera
in boom
there you go
right
so it we're kind of in live view we can
change to our let's see where you at
under perspective if we go to cinematic
viewport
and i believe
we need to select
the camera
yes if we select camera and this
existing camera
we should be seeing this i don't know
why
cinematic viewport
do we need to pilot this thing
again
pilot it okay won't let us pilot it
default viewport forget the cinematic
viewport i was trying to do a thing
but now it's not doing anything okay
g
hider stuff
let's
get back into this camera why can't i
not get up in this camera
let me delete this
and this
and try again
uh yo i don't know
what is going on
but it will not let me up in this camera
right now
maybe that's a restart
do i need to get out of the sequence
do i need to delete the sequence
let's try again
okay yep
we'll try again uh animation
level sequence let's get up in there
let's drag our camera in i know we need
that camera
um and
we have it to 150 frames
that's really all we need at this point
and
we want to export this right we want to
export this
i also want to be at well this doesn't
matter
30 fps we'll change that later
we want to export this to the movie
render queue and this little clapboard
right here
if i
hit the ellipsis you can choose which
one you're going to go through we want
the movie render queue all right that's
going to give us a lot more options uh
to export this in the highest quality
possible right
bam movie render queue brings up this
dialog box right here now for some of
you that might not be available that's
because you need to go to settings
plugins and you need to type
render
queue
and check movie render queue on
that's what you need to do
to use what i'm about to show y'all
restart your engine and you'll be good
to go alright so
up in here
we can click on this unsaved layout we
don't want to export a jpeg sequence we
want to export a exr sequence and i
think the dwa compression works the best
holds the highest quality for the lowest
file size all right we can get rid of
jpeg sequence all right we just want
that exr sequence it's going to give us
the most control over our image later
when we're doing color correction and
whatnot
um output
let's find a place for it
so yeah i did 10 tests this is uh the
stream
render
that's where it's going okay going in
that folder
output res 1920x1080 is good i was doing
um 4k
so
by 2160
you guys can do what you want but for
this we're keeping that resolution we
also want a custom frame rate of 24 fps
because the cinematic frame rate is 24
not 30 not 48 not 60 it's 24 fps that's
what our eyeballs are used to
seeing in the movies right
um
that should honestly be everything we
need uh for this output it's going into
the right place right resolution right
frame rate okay
but there's one more thing we got to do
that is the move and that is how we get
the highest quality settings so
if i go to settings and i bring up
console variables okay this
is the secret settings the secret sauce
and i have a video
that goes over all of this in detail
um which i will probably link to
once this stream is over
but it's like all the things i learned
in unreal in a year basically is the
name of the video or something it's like
the the dance club scene
i go over my whole process on that
and we're going to add these console
variable variables right we're going to
add a bunch i already have
them saved as a preset console variables
um
rtx right i'll pull this one up
console variables boom
and i have all these console variables
screen percentage r dot screen
percentage this one is the best okay so
what this does
is let's say we're exporting it
30 40 by 2160 no thanks i want that 1920
by 1080.
yep
what it's gonna do console variables
it's uh by default it's set to 100 so if
we just do it as 100 and we hit render
it's going to render a 1920 by 1080
image but if i type in 200 it's gonna
multiply it by two you can do 150 as
well if you want to do
by 1.5
but it's going to multiply it by
whatever number you type here
and it's going to render out a larger
in our case two times it's going to
render a 4k render but it's going to
scale it down to fit 1920 by 1080. so
it's gonna look really crisp
i love that one that's such a good one
um and then we have all these other ones
ambient occlusion denoiser zero direct
uh diffusion direct denoiser zero we're
setting all our denoisers to zero uh
we're maxing out our motion blur quality
um
we are maxing out our depth of field
quality we're maxing out our bloom
quality we probably don't need that
because
we don't have bloom
that's okay i to be honest don't know if
having the console variable set here
adds render time if we don't have bloom
in our scene i don't know that yet
um tone mapper quality is five so these
are all
settings based off of um
unreal engine documentation that they
suggest for highest settings use these
and then we have our ray tracing
settings and that's what i was talking
about earlier
where
you don't have to view the highest
settings in your viewport because it's
you're going to be chugging but you type
them in here so when you render it
renders the highest quality so we have
the ray tracing global illumination
denoiser set to zero
we have r.raytracing.shadow.samples
per pixel set to 64. and i think to be
honest it's supposed to be shadows
plural
ray tracing reflections samples per
pixel set to 64 and ray tracing
reflections shadows set to 2 alright
um
y'all can just copy this
when you watch it later when you're
doing this um and definitely make sure
you
save it as a preset so you have to type
these every time please
and the last thing the thing that's
helping our plants look nice and crisp
in the wind
is anti-aliasing so that's another one
that we go to settings and we grab
anti-aliasing
and the one thing i'm doing is i am
setting this temporal sample count to
64. so it's going to render 64 images
per frame essentially i'm going to set
this to 32 just for example on the
stream so we can get through our final
image a little faster and then i'm
checking this override anti-aliasing box
okay and that's all you got to do for
the anti-aliasing to set it up right
we'll accept
and i am going to cross my fingers
drink some water and hit render and see
how this goes
you'll get this low quality preview
which will pop up and we just make sure
that we're rendering the right from the
right camera and it looks kind of like
how
it's looking in our scene so let's see
what it looks like real quick
whoa
i know what's happening
we're we're um we're seeing our floor
so let me cut this off
when you hide stuff in the outliner
it isn't safe from the render the render
catches all so the floor bye bye
i think that's what was popping through
landscape
go bye-bye
let's try it again shall we
save everything ctrl shift s render
local and now we should be getting a uh
a more reasonable
one um
patchy you said it's it's ray tracing
shadow not shadows
you might be right but uh
the other day
it it said it was wrong and i and i
thought it was shadow
but it actually is shadows
and it might be a different shadow thing
i'm
i'm thinking of but
all right so it's going it's going and
it's taking a minute right
it's gonna take a while i'm gonna stop
this and i'm gonna do something just for
the stream that is reasonable so
whoa
let's uh
let's bring it back around
can't be a stream unless you have a
crash just one right
oh papaxo you are right we can check um
uncheck visible
so if that floor was still there we can
uncheck visible
um all right let's
open the level round two
yes let's pilot that camera
um and i will say guys this is the
difference between doing this on stream
and
taking a day
tweaking all those settings that i was
tweaking
so they're similar it's a little darker
here
but it's not much different to be honest
with you
this let me just
grab this right here
and let me open up the other one
open level round two
we'll go into the camera
and i'll snap this real quick
um
we'll compare these
in pure f
all right so that's what we just did
and
dang it
come on now
i'm just curious
i'm curious
boom
pilot this thing bam this looks like a
little darker maybe
the water
is lumen water
so that's the difference it's just a
little darker
the shrubs are a little darker
um i think lumen does a nice job of
getting some nice shadows in those
bushes
and this is just
setting tweaking settings tweaking
tweaking tweaking my settings
um
the difference between these two
but we're going to make it look nice in
after effects so
um if i go back to my orig or to the one
that i just did with you guys
and we set the lighting let's go back to
our post process
and we type in reflections
oh no not there sorry post process
type reflections
go back to lumen
yep yep yep okay i wonder if there's
like a lighting uh let's see let's try
global illumination is lumen if we did
raytrace global illumination
yeah that looks nice
so let's just changing the lighting
method
lumen global illumination
we could set
uh let's see ray trace global
elimination advanced reflections
ray trace reflections screen space
ray trace ray traced um ambient
occlusion ray traced ambient occlusion
yeah
why not um
let's
set that to like four or something um
ray tracing translucency
will that help our water perhaps
check those on
path tracing we can we can try path
tracing i don't think it works with the
water or the fog
but um let's let's render this out again
shall we
let's do it um
okay
post-process volume i think i'm gonna go
just one more time with the color
correction
and our gamma
and i'm going to go with 0.8 i think it
looks a little nicer
and
i'll take the fog see i can just tweak
forever you know what i'm saying
take the fog to like point four
wait why is that not doing anything
oh it is but it's just like a subtle
thing
okay
all right let's do it let's let's do it
let's render okay let's render let's go
back to our sequence
let's pull up that dialog box okay
um let's load
those console variable settings
anti-aliasing let's just set it to
12.
no 16 16.
console variables the screen percentage
i will probably set this to 100 default
so it doesn't do it just for the stream
um
yeah exr and tlsing high settings good
stuff let's give this a shot if this
doesn't
let me make sure my output is good
if this still takes forever i'll just
do like 1280 by 720 or something
foxtrot yes there is a way to convert
all models in level to nanite all you
have to do is select all your meshes
right click them go to the very top
option called nanite and enable it that
is it
that is yup
all right so it's still taking a minute
per frame but it's okay it's okay
because
basically i'm gonna show you guys just
like what i'm doing uh color correction
wise uh to spice up the image and all we
need is really one image to do that on
and we can kind of work as it renders
oh i am running 4k at the moment thank
you sir
and you are right it looks
no see look look look look look look
r.ray
r.raytracing.shadow
dot samples per pixel
it doesn't recognize
that console variable
and i think that's because they changed
it i think it needs to be
shadows
boom
plural crazy huh um you're right
1920 by
1080
accept
save
render
we doing it right
secret gupta
yes
all my live streams are always available
after the fact i never take anything
down so you guys will be good
it's running a lot faster now let's open
up after effects and see what we can do
oh
new project
let's go ahead and open up
our stream render boom bring it in drag
it into a new composition okay
so
here's a little tip for you guys ctrl k
in after effects will open up your
composition settings
um this is in this is in terms of time i
don't want time i want uh frames if you
control click the time code over here
you'll go to frame count and then if you
hit ctrl k again bam we'll get our
frames
we want to ensure that this is coming in
at 24fps so if we right-click we go to
interpret footage main
24 is the way um if it's coming in as
something different if you go to file
project setting nope if you go
to edit
preferences import
you can change the default import frame
rate and i have it set to 24. it changes
based on the project i'm working on so
i'll change that so i have to keep
changing it you know what i mean
let's open this up
now if i right click this and i reload
the footage it's going to update
with me but i'm going to drag it out
like you saw me just drag it out right
um and soto actually do you mind just
dropping my little my head
down below
into the corner there that'd be nice
or even top top or
bottom right no bottom
what is the chat no
we can just go i don't know somewhere
other than there i trust you you know
i'm going to be in the bottom left
working anyway so
um let's see
what i was gonna say
was instead of having to right click
and reload and drag this out every time
i learned this one from ren if you right
click you go to time enable time
remapping you drag this out once
all the way to the end you just drag it
to the end
and then you turn it off you uncheck
that stopwatch every time i right click
and reload it'll auto update like that i
don't have to drag it out every time
[Music]
let us
i'm gonna be i'm just do this not the
right way and desktop this i'm i'm
unforgivable um what are you gonna call
this stream delete i don't need this
later
um okay
so
color correction first and foremost uh
alt ctrl shift y it's going to make an
adjustment layer or you can go to layer
new
adjustment layer and this is just
something that is invisible unless you
put something on it and i want to put a
lumetri color
for color correction and i am using vc
console
i think is the name of it from video
copilot if you hit control spacebar you
can type whatever you want it is a game
changer fx console is what it's called i
think
basic color correction let's uh
we we want deeper shadows
oh i made a null object i'm telling you
guys the wrong shortcut
ctrl alt y that's what you want
all right so probably some deeper
shadows i know i want a vignette let me
actually start with the vignette so
control y
for
a solid we're gonna choose
nearly black dark gray is good
make it comp size
hit okay
boom if you hold this down
this little mask option we can select
ellipse and if you double click it it'll
just default get out
with the solid selected if you double
click this it'll just default to uh the
bounds
of yours your composition and we're
gonna set that to subtract
f for feather and
we're gonna feather it ctrl shift h will
hide
your different uh
you know ui stuff or you can just click
this little button here toggling the
mask on and off
um i like to set this vignette to
overlay it's more of a natural
blending option
and
i'm gonna adjust let's this do like 600
or something yeah that's looking pretty
good
i could even do one more or rather just
bring this back
come on now
and
just give me a little bit there
yeah
that looks nice
i'm happy with that now we can kind of
adjust
our color correction so let's
drop the shadows a little bit
um
let's get some bloom going
so i'm gonna duplicate the render ctrl d
and i'm gonna give it a tint
to turn it black and white i'm going to
give it levels
so we can really crunch the contrast and
then i'm going to use a
plug-in called frictiloof
fl out of focus it's the best
camera blur plug-in that i've come
across
free schluft
fl out of focus or you can just use
fast blur whatever
the point is we just want to blur out
this background okay so basically we're
focusing on bloom here i want to first
crunch
the image let's turn off tint for now
let's first crunch it
so we only want to deal with
that white sky
will crunch the heck out of it
maybe bring the gamma down
[Music]
something like that it looks horrible
and then we're gonna hit
tint because we still want a little bit
of the natural color to come through but
not too much
that's fine and then we blur the heck
out of it so like
i don't know what does 5 do
20.
20 might be the
the move
and i might just kind of come back on
that a little bit
also i think if we're if we hold alt we
can switch to a 16 bit project file you
hit the 8 bit
and you'll notice the difference we have
this banding if you hold alt and you
change to a 16 bit project file that
banning
really cleans up
but you guys probably won't see that on
the stream
um now if we set this to
screen
we got some bloom but that's obviously
too much so i'm gonna hit t and just
turn it off completely it's hit zero
um and then let's kind of walk it back
in
it's 20 percent enough is
50
probably a little much
maybe we go 35 percent so it's subtle
right
um and then
let's go ahead
and
boost the highlights
so it's a little bit
just a touch brighter
i like that yeah that's pretty good
let's reload our render right click
reload footage
bam
right so we got these plants moving we
got the water rippling it's looking nice
um
it's too crisp it's too crisp okay so
i want to
just soften it a touch this is a 4k
monitor so at 200 percent
it is a little uh low-res
right because we're going beyond what we
rendered but if it was a 4k render
i
just want to throw a quick fast blur on
it so i'm gonna throw a fast blur of
one
on the render
which is too much
0.5 is too much
0.1
is probably all we need
it takes it from
crisp render
to
filmed with a camera
so a little bit of blur goes a long long
long way i'll probably just do 0.15 on
that or something cool
um we have our bloom which is helping we
have our color correction which is just
touching up those shadows a little bit
and we have our vignette which is doing
most of the work for us now we have
grain to talk about as well
so you can bake in your green from
unreal if you all want that's totally
fine um
what
i do though i use a
thing called
we got overlays no no no where is it
gorilla grain is what it's called
stock footage
lens effects gorilla grain
brain
35 mil
pack fine clean that's the one
i love it
bam
this is very subtle
y'all you probably won't be able to see
this too much on youtube but
you're probably seeing more than i
assume you're seeing i set that to
overlay and by default i think it
brightens our image
so i like to throw a little bit of
levels on it just to
get the gamma right in the middle there
and that
will maintain
our brightness level but that goes a
long way it's very subtle but it goes a
long way
takes it away from a render and more
towards like it was shot
with a camera boom
um
that's pretty much it guys that is
pretty much it
uh another thing i did was add a little
bit of camera shake to the final
so there's definitely different ways to
do this um
both of them require you to select
everything hit ctrl shift c
and pre-compose your image i think you
can also right-click and find
pre-compose bam right here
you want to pre-compose all these
different layers into its own folder
we're going to move all these attributes
into the new composition so now we just
have
all of our stuff
in one place
you can do a quick expression so on the
position right you can alt click the
position and we can hit wiggle
right that's going to
allow us to wiggle the camera
um
i think the first number is the
frequency the second number is the
amount let's find out
so if we have a frequency of 100 like i
said i always like to go overboard to
see what's going on
and we want to move
it
in x or y direction by five pixels
we should get some really intense micro
shake yep so i was right first number's
frequency second number is
um
like the amount like the distance how
far it's shaking
so we probably don't need anything more
than like
five
let's see what that looks like
that's too much it's definitely too much
i think it's um
frequency needs to be like two
and the distance needs to be like three
super subtle
even that i feel like is is not quite
right i think maybe
a distance of three and maybe a
frequency of six
getting closer we can do five and two
not bad that's a little bit better yeah
okay
something very subtle um you'll notice
it's going beyond
the frame here um you can see yep
that's no good so you can just scale it
in this case it's not shaking so much we
can just do like 101
and you're set right
and that is
that is it
you know you get your buddy to record
some music for you some some ambient
music you put it to this and you're
having a good time
that i think that's it guys that
concludes uh
concludes the environment i did it my
goal was to get to a final as quickly as
possible um i guess the one thing i
didn't show you guys was how to model
this totem in c4d y'all are probably in
blender
um
but that's okay
maybe i'll give you a quick overview
how are you guys feeling
you guys doing good um
that was fun
that was great like i had so much fun
setting that up and working on that
environment over the week
i think it's a really good way for me to
learn to create stuff that i'm proud of
and
ultimately prepping for this stream
um at the same time it's the bob ross
method you know
he painted three paintings the first
painting was done before the show we got
a grasp on what he was doing the second
painting was the live painting during
the show and then he did a third
painting after the fact
taking into account everything he
learned to paint the painting that was
like the painting
um i don't think i'm gonna do this a
third time but i'll do another
environment and i think it's it's really
fun if you guys like this definitely
consider subscribing if you guys learned
something i'm almost at a million holy
crap i am almost not a million so if you
all are not subscribed to this point
definitely y'all know what to do hit the
bell do the stuff
um and just come back hang out with me
it's always chill here we're always
learning something new trying to create
cool stuff together
um so good vibes only good vibes only
uh yeah it also like you know you guys
know
friggin let me know what you guys want
to see more of i want to do more of
these environments than unreal i want to
help you guys learn unreal i want to
demystify the program it's not as scary
as it seems um you're never going to
make progress if you don't
hop in and i think now it's just
becoming easier than ever to hop in
especially
with william foshea doing his tutorials
especially with unreal engine 5 just
making things a lot easier now's the
time to get in y'all get in while the
getting is good
um
but i'm gonna hang out with y'all for a
little bit answer some questions if you
guys have any
questions please just add me here
i'll answer any questions you guys may
have about unreal about life
um and then we're gonna get into the
weekly challenge winners i'll announce
those
and i'm probably gonna go get some pizza
get some pizza
yeah
heck yeah
that was fun that was super fun
i feel very accomplished with this one
um it gave me a chance to revisit
uh st john's newfoundland
that place is the freaking best if you
guys are all about fog and stormy
weather go to st john's newfoundland
because
it's amazing one thing i don't think i
touched on actually
um and i may have mentioned this i know
i mentioned this
but i don't know if i mentioned it here
um
coming up with ideas right coming up
with ideas for renders it can be
difficult sometimes
and i love
very very much
going out with this camera right here
this is the film
film camera it's a nike matt ftn it's
the camera i used to take the
all my film photos on
it is rusted now this thing has been
rusted so i have to get a new film
camera it makes me very sad this thing
is the best it's like
six pounds seven pounds of just metal
all mechanical this thing's the best it
was a japanese camera
in the 70s late 70s
um anyway i'm a scatter brain right back
on topic
going out taking photos whether it's
with your have it be your phone it
doesn't have to be a film camera
whatever gets you excited to take photos
that's what you want to be doing right
go out um go on a hike go on a trip go
out of country whatever go travel please
go travel if you can go travel i know
that covet is a thing but it's starting
to ramp down it's been ramped down i'm
ready to travel i am dying to travel
bring a camera with you take your own
pictures learn how to use if you want to
step up from the phone
you know grab a cheap digital camera um
sony has a lot of good stuff
um
learn how camera works because then
you're gonna learn how to better direct
your scenes in 3d it all comes from this
right here
so
long story long story
i'm out taking photos love taking photos
i come back and i have a batch of photos
that
inspire me to create more 3d stuff
and the whole point of me saying all
this is
use your own photos
as reference
to recreate and then you can add things
to them that weren't there originally um
you know the
mortality run piece of art i did with
the car rocking
with the wind and the ocean and the
factory in the back that's that was
inspired from a photo that i took in
newfoundland as well
um and i just added a bunch of stuff to
it i just kept going kept adding kept
adding
and i can certainly do that to this you
know to this thing that we just created
and you guys can too it keeps your art
original you're referencing you're
copying your own stuff
that's freaking great that's great copy
your own stuff all day long recreate
your own stuff
um and
it also keeps it more original too
because it's from you it's your thing
it's a great way to learn so
next time you're out take some photos
maybe do some recreations could be fun
but let's get to some questions you guys
are up in here
with some good questions we still got
470 people in the chat i really
appreciate you guys thank you for
hanging out with me
um people who are working in
unreal for should they move to ue5 yes
finish your projects in ue4 finish them
and move on to 5.
in my experience
yes in my experience yes if you're part
of a big studio
and you know there's so many people
working in unreal 4.27 or whatever
version they ended up on
that's a higher level decision there
might be reasons why it's not
safe to move on yet because five is
came out it's publicly released it's not
in beta anymore
there's a lot of beta plug-ins i mean
i love five because it it builds stuff
for you it does stuff for you that you
would have to like spend so much time
tweaking tweaking tweaking to get
looking right lumen takes care of that
also nanite allows you to just fill your
scene with so much stuff
um
so i love it
hypoxia am i excited to judge the rococo
loop challenge heck yeah heck yeah well
it's gonna be me uh wren
i think peter and william foshae
the four of us with sam from rococo
we're gonna be judging these loop
uh renders i've seen some of them from
y'all on the discord
and i can't wait to dive in it's gonna
be fun
um where are the clouds in the render yo
there are no clouds in the render
because
well technically we're in the cloud in
the render because it's fog
so
we're in a cloud
um
snowflake films my textures and meshes
look blurry when i import them from
qixel into ue5 as a way to fix it i use
nanite quality setting in quicksole
they look blurry
um
i
don't know
i don't know you can try
disabling nanite in the mesh try
disabling nanite and see if it looks
better
also try rendering it and seeing if what
you render looks
different than what you're looking at in
the live viewer perhaps
but it's kind of difficult to
to say without seeing it um can i share
my comma music playlist
yes it is called ambient for
vfx
and reflection
let's see it's on spotify
if you type ambient
underscore for underscore vfx and
reflection i'll share this with you guys
right here in the chat
um
yeah i listen to this music all the time
to
let's see let me grab this uh
copy link
bam
uh ambient
playlist for you guys
boom yeah i'm up on that all the time
it helps me it inspires my work
i listen to it i listen to it all week
while making this piece of art um
so it's a it's a no-brainer for me
uh is it possible that lumen and nanite
come on apple silicon who knows man i
don't know
um it's a shame it's not on there at
this point but
yeah i'm sure i am sure
need more unreal streams for sure ghost
trigger i got you definitely it's gonna
happen maybe get william on for another
stream i would love that i swear every
time he talks i learned something new i
agree
yup you're speaking the truth
um what else astronomy live is ue5
compatible with making vr experiences
yet heard it wasn't compatible with vr
out of the gate um
i am sure you can do vr stuff with it
but i'm just talking about but at this
point
i've never done it myself
um
yeah i
i know that like vr is them is literally
the most taxing
on unreal
and
i don't know soto is telling me here in
my ear he doesn't think lumen and nanite
work with vr because it's like a
it only works with one camera as opposed
to two cameras at the same time
so i don't know if it works for vr yet
i do not know
um
will my wife make a stream appearance
probably not probably not
maybe her arm will pop in at some time
and like give me a cookie or something
she does it sometimes she'll like bring
me a kombucha or a cookie
but i don't think she'll say who knows i
think she did one time like early on
but she usually hangs out with friends
while i'm streaming so
digital boost
your lessons
have made a very wise man have made you
a very wise man you know i do what i can
i do what i can as to you or trying to
try and get through this and uh learn as
much as possible but i appreciate that
anish does fong angle matter when
importing mods from c40 to unreal five
um
it's looking unsmooth
sorry very new to unreal five um i don't
know if phong angle
matters in unreal five to be honest with
you i don't know
um
but i think i've ran into that problem
before
i would check
the stream i did
with
steve begin it's an unreal stream i did
with steve begin back in the archives um
i think we may have ran into that
in that stream
so check that one out
and use
if you're doing c4d use um
the data smith importer so you're gonna
go to plugins in unreal engine
and you're gonna type data smith you'll
check that import your stuff that way
from c4d i think that could also help
you
um
what else
have i thought about doing some interior
design experiments in unreal five we
normally work inside of redshift and c4d
but the looks of things unreal could do
a decent job for some setups absolutely
man yeah i want to do some interior
stuff i want to do
um a series on like uh
um
like steam rooms saunas onsen kind of
stuff i love mia's theme room uh the
lighting in there is nice it's foggy
it's totally up my alley so
i want to do some interior
foggy steam room stuff um
but yeah i mean with lumen i'm telling
you with lumen and the bounce light the
global illumination is off the charts
interior design is
perfect with unreal five this is amazing
ah
what else what else you guys got
a couple more questions and then i'm
gonna do this weekly challenge
let's see
thanks digital boost
have i seen the new season of death and
robots i have actually i've seen half of
it i've seen half of it
um
i thought it was pretty cool
yeah i thought it was pretty sweet
uh definitely the last episode was my
favorite
in terms of the look i watched episode
three the one y'all said was like my
render challenge
is there's no way
that that that it's the same thing like
a dude is dragon you know she's dragging
her dead friend
across the wasteland
if i were to drag anyone across the
wastes and you're tethered together is
part of the story i'm gonna do it that
way also there's only so many ways you
can capture that action going through an
environment
so it was just
it just happened to work for their story
i don't think it was a thing but it
looked like it didn't it was funny
um
what else is unreal 5 worth learning if
you're into making movies i started
learning blender for vfx
yes worth absolutely
absolutely
um i i will say that like
you know you know when you buy two video
games and then you don't finish both of
them
or either of them right like you kind of
want to finish one game and then go to
another
i wouldn't say it's like exactly like
that but it might be like that
especially at first because if if
blender is completely new to you
and you start learning it's like
learning the piano and then you learn
the trumpet
as long as you keep learning them like
just don't whatever you got to do for
you to keep that fire going do it
unreal is deep unreal unreal can be very
um
intimidating
so
honestly like keep watching these
streams check out william foche
he he'll he'll guide you in the right
spot um he'll make it seem easy for you
so
check him out just watch this tutorial
see what see what's good uh wind bush is
another good one too
uh the one thing you never really find
online is niagara vacant dealing with
getting the ability for ffx for players
to follow terrain slope the loving
in-depth tutorial i don't know much
about that i'll be honest with you
um
yeah i'm not really about
making games in unreal or rather
that could be mistaken um
it's not what i'm trying to use unreal
for
i'm trying to use unreal for cinematic
storytelling so i i don't know
i wish i could offer more on that spidey
gaming thoughts on zbrush
yeah
i had difficulty with it uh using it
this year for uni use blender variant
for final project instantly felt more
comfortable look i would say
whatever
whatever
uh program or software
gets you excited to create
that's the program you should be using
so
at a certain point maybe zbrush will be
your answer because you might find
there's limitations
with whatever you're using now and then
it's like i gotta figure out something
next
and zbrush is you know z brush is there
it's not going away
um
i have not used zbrush
like i used it once maybe 10 years ago
but
creating characters is on my list
it's it's probably next it's such a
weak point for me i need to get better
at it
will i add houdini to my workflow
probably not i'm gonna keep going with
unreal for now
and then
it's all it all comes down to the art i
want to make
right
um and for me that's environments
atmospheric environments
i love it it's the best and unreal makes
it so darn easy so
yeah
yeah
but i'll learn as i need to you know i'm
not saying no
to anything it's just a matter of what
i'm trying to do all
um couple more do you recommend any art
books i remember uh remember you
recommending some before like
construction zone
dude i'll yeah yeah absolutely
absolutely oh what steve begin
i was just talking about you i was just
talking about you um we had a question
from someone saying when they bring
stuff
from c4d into unreal everything looks
jagged like the phong angle is it
doesn't look smooth and i remember us
running into that problem i don't
remember if it was like on the stream
but do you do you know
how that works is there a way to import
something and like have like a ball
you know your sphere imported from c40
looks smooth as opposed to like a
freaking geodisc
um
that's great that's freaking great steve
began popping in like right as we were
talking about you i don't know if you
were here when i brought you up first
but that's pretty great
can you link steve or uh can you link
will focus
tutorials
just google how to make unreal cinematic
and he's the man
guy with the beard
filmed from like up here
this angle with a nice soft box that's
your boy
um
do i have any resources if you want to
move from doing renders in unreal 5 to
actual game design
oh
i have not looked up game design
tutorials i would start with just a
youtube search
from there um i would
look up
any sort of
tutorials i go to like epic games or go
to unreal engine
uh
the unreal engine
resource page
in the epic games launcher
and they have a tutorial area like a
resources area and they have a bunch of
like courses and stuff for free so check
that out
namaste from india yo yo thoughts on c
plus and its importance
when it comes to unreal five i don't
know a freaking speck of c plus plus so
maybe it makes you better in unreal five
but
i don't i'm not using it
um thanks ronin for
[Music]
for grabbing will's channel there i'll
pin it
okay guys let's let's talk about the
weekly challenge
winners all right because the challenge
was
uh was monument you had a week to create
a monument render
uh and we're gonna talk about this right
now so soto
if you can share your screen which it
looks like you already yeah can you
share your screen so i can see what's
going on
and then we'll hop into it uh
let's see let's see
what are you
hold on guys we'll be there in two two
seconds
yeah restart it
weird it's just oh wait no there it is
there it is
all right sorry guys
all right
let's talk about these uh
these winners here
are review let's hop on over
yeah okay
so like i said the weekly challenge was
monument
you guys had a week to render whatever
that meant to you i picked the winners
we got some honorable mentions to get
into
this is all done on the discord server
linked below
you guys get 15 points if you win five
points if you get honorable mention
um and that upgrades your rank you can
level up and everything um and climb to
the ranks and
have a sweet badge to show off so first
off
the first winner of the monument weekly
challenge is elliott
with the classic
classic render y'all from 2001
space odyssey i think this is so well
done it's your lighting man
your lighting is what looks so darn good
i wonder if this is unreal
i wonder
um but dude your sky looks great your
lighting looks great
very soft and buttery
your composition is spot on the blocking
and placement of the apes is spot on
um
your grass maybe you can use a little
bit more but whatever
it's looking solid dude your your assets
are placed nicely uh your render quality
is really really great you're firing on
all cylinders man so congratulations
elliott for the challenge winner roll
this week you get into that pro tier
lounge
um
it's going to be a good time you get
those 15 points it's gonna be solid
who do we have next we got oren cloud up
next yes dude i love you need your own
art book
because all of your renders are looking
so darn good they're in this style
what a beautiful portfolio you have it's
so cool to see you putting stuff out of
this quality every single week
another thing too we have streaks so if
you post i think if you do uh
consistently post three times
then you will be on streak
and you'll get uh your your badge your
art badge will go
it'll catch on fire super sick um
this looks great dude holy crap the
lighting on this is ridiculous
the composition is ridiculous your
colors are amazing
framing is really nice um the skulls
look a little they almost look like they
are
untextured i know they got some
subsurface on them it looks like
but i like part of me wants that skull
texture you know what i mean
um but my goodness congratulations to
you for winning the weekly challenge
oren cloud
super solid stuff who do we got next
it's our boy ronin our very own ronin
one of the moderators and when a
moderator wins everyone can win okay
just because someone's a moderator
doesn't mean they can't win this is
purely based on the art alone okay
um
no one's getting any special treatment
the art if the art's good the art's good
and if we have
a moderator win like ronan just did
right now
what we do is
that moderator so ronan will choose one
of the honorable mentions and
gift
the challenge winner role to that
honorable mention so
it's not like he's taking up a spot or
anything just just to make that clear
this is beautiful
really solid lighting i love it when a
foreground element
is out of focus in this like big scene
like this it makes it feel like
just so massive
and you know there's there's different
different movies that do this kind of
shot it's a very basic thing it's just a
shallow depth of field but when it's
across such a wide landscape like this
usually you have to have a much
you have to have nd filters you have to
have a real
low aperture lens which it's hard to do
in real life
especially when you're so zoomed out at
like a you know
25 mil or a 20 mil
like this might be
it's just a really cool look i dig it
and it's good color good lighting
nice little statue
or stash statuesque
um it's just monolith coming up out of
the ground these two buildings so
congrats ronan very good stuff
next up we have skye
going classic this is definitely this is
a monument for sure
um
it's so good it's lit so well it's so
clear it's so clean and crisp
it just works it's freaking solid
you did a really good job with your
composition you framed it well you
vignetted it with your natural with
those trees there
which is always a great hack it's always
you know you're vignetting your subject
naturally with the trees if you go back
to ronan's you can see he did the same
thing he's vignetting his um
uh those buildings with those foreground
pipes
and the character and everything so very
similar but yeah skye really good stuff
congratulations on the win that's
looking really great keep it up and i
hope to see you
doing some cool stuff next week as well
and finally the last winner is zeus
creates
my goodness i love the color on this one
man i love the color i know you were
here on the stream
previously i hope you're still here
but
man it's looking good i really love your
lighting and your color on this
um
and your angle too it's not a typical
angle that you'd see so i wonder like
did you use reference for this
did you find something that inspired you
to choose this angle because it's not
like
a go-to angle you know i really dig it
it's really really nice i think the only
thing
i'd add would probably be just more
detail more shrubs more plants uh on the
outskirts of things
um
could probably help a little bit
but man other than that dude this is
freaking great your god rays are solid
the birds are looking good i'd love to
see the animated version
but let's hop into the honorable
mentions all right we got our five
winners
first up i want to shout out capes on my
back
with this nice
little monument this forest monument you
got your little uh your reference up top
little easter egg up top on that thing i
just love this lush forest environment i
think it's beautiful it's framed nicely
it's lit nicely it's composed nicely
you're doing really good stuff so keep
it up feisty cadaver is next which you
got
very simon stalin hag extremely simon
stalinhack
um but he's one of the one of the greats
so
you're doing doing a good job
um
being inspired by some of the best you
know you're doing a solid job with the
atmosphere behind that monolith
to
silhouette it
right you kind of lose it if you just
had the trees but you put that cloud
layer back there and it really does a
good job of uh
of making that pop good lighting too uh
jimmy dubs is next
freaking great i love the red green
uh really good color contrast it's a
good way to
pop your subject out if it's contrasting
colors
um
good cloud layer there too nice and
puffy pixar looking clouds pretty nice
environment too
i think you could probably hide the seam
of the water and the rock there
uh on your lake
on the left side with maybe some more
shrubs
more smaller rocks or something
and a character maybe on that hilltop
having a picnic in like a yellow or
blue dress
that's dying for a subject why is there
no something that's even lit there for a
subject yeah
oh there's a person
it's too tiny
it's so tiny i can't see it
i eat my own words lord cabbage lord
cabbage is next
classic man
super good you're doing the same thing
you're framing your uh
your subject here
naturally with the trees with the
mountains
shining a bright light behind them to
silhouette them and really put the focus
on your statue as good composition
that's good lighting and i want to shout
you out that's good stuff luco is next
you're doing cool stuff here i love your
lighting i love the idea
this is really cool and you dude you're
doing it y'all are catching on you got
your vignette natural vignette with the
rocks in the foreground
shaping your image and directing your
eye towards the the subject which i'd
say is
the this this rocky
masked character and then your eye
definitely goes down to the character
just below so you're doing it killing it
really good stuff uh mod over mesh
we got you next freaking love this man
this
came close to winning for me
i love your color your green cyan yellow
such a beautiful palette so lush i love
like the painterly layer you have on top
i want to be here i want to be here
ah
you're killing it such a good job
great work marcus seem
i think is your name you went classic
you went literal with it the washington
monument
and it's freaking great this is near
photo reel it's lit beautifully
beautifully and you chose a perfect time
of day to represent
um yeah man hats off to you that's
really good stuff metatrox is next
real interesting um scene here very like
high fantasy
kind of vibes i'm getting here
um i'd probably move your moon out from
behind that rock it's like a little
bit make it a little smaller pop it out
to the left a little bit more maybe
your character on the bottom left i'd
probably get them in
a little bit more
featured a little bit more um
i want to see this person on the robot
there would be the true subject i feel
like your subject is just out of frame a
little too much your lighting is
beautiful
killed the lighting man really good
stuff on the lighting
um and i think there's some sort of like
character holding out their hands with a
waterfall
cave situation going on in their in
their head or their hood
i'm missing that a little bit i wish i
could see that that is a person a little
bit more as opposed to
it just looks like a rock if i squint
it's just a rock you know so
i'd work on trying to frame them a
little bit more
um you could potentially do that with
like a
light layer like if you were to
oh it's the best way to describe this um
on their left side the shadow side
they just kind of need a rim light
essentially
so maybe you pop them out from that rock
a little bit more or something i don't
know
but it's really good stuff
the lighting is what is my favorite the
colors too super solid
of course the atmosphere anyway moving
on edward you're next
um beautiful man really good detail
really good render um
your lighting is solid
i love your scene again your
silhouetting your
subject
your monolith
naturally with those ice walls
um and i just loved your lighting and
your puffy snow
down below it looks it looks really good
so
shout outs tia and uh next up we have
monument to cats underscore cc i don't
know if that's your name
but i like what you said you said
in a way it's the tallest thing in the
room
and it's basically a monument to cats
and your render quality was so freaking
nice that i had to give you a little
shout out here i think it looks
beautiful so congrats purbosky is next
this is really cool this is like the i
think the only person
who went this far modeling wise on their
monument and it actually looking this
nice you featured it's not about your
environment really it's about your
monument so i think you modeled a really
cool thing
um you lit it well it's colored nicely
and uh yeah it definitely piqued my
interest so it's good stuff and we have
game factory shout outs the game factory
dude yes
freaking love your lighting love your
lighting and the angle super solid too
great detail
great scene that you have going on here
super creepy very cinematic
uh yeah dude this is killer very good
stuff and i think lastly we have triogi
beautiful this this reminds me a little
bit of love deaf and deaf yeah love
death and robots
i wonder if it was inspired by that um
you had two versions you had an oil
painting filter and you just had the
render i preferred just the render so i
grabbed that one the oil painting
filters seem too much like a filter
that's a tough one that's a world that i
hadn't dipped into yet the filter world
but i know there's some really good
stuff out there so
definitely keep doing your research
the trick is to not make it look like a
filter
that's the that's the hard part
um but this is awesome dude you've got
some nice god rays coming in here
uh it's a really nice setup my only
my only thing was like i don't really
see the monolith
i don't see the monument
um
so
that would be my biggest note because it
probably just needs to better match the
the prompt
a little bit more but i think your
lighting is solid i think your render
quality is solid so keep it up just try
and try and i'm sure you had your way
i'm sure you had your thoughts on why it
matched but uh i know there's a
structure away out there
just hard to see
and that's it y'all
that is it uh congratulations to the
winners
and if you guys want to participate in
the new weekly challenge like i said
we're running them every single week
down in the description we got the link
to the discord come hop in with us we
got a good community of people there is
a patreon
version
of the discord server but you honestly
you get most of it for free um we are
kind of going back and forth on what's
free what's patreon and we felt we've
always felt that the weekly challenges
should be open to everybody because we
don't want to hold back the education
from everyone
um patreon gets you like patreon lounge
game nights we'll hop in for game nights
once a month
that kind of stuff and
as far as the discord server is involved
but
yeah i think this prompt is a
useless invention or something like that
i'm pretty sure it's a useless invention
and uh it'll be fun create your own
useless invention should be cool
but i'm gonna keep working on some
environments i'm very excited to keep
going with that um
i will be posting a video so this is my
stream for the month i stream once a
month and i post once a month so two
videos per month
definitely subscribe if you guys want to
catch my next video that's coming out
um and it's going to be on how
to create
an in-depth environment in unreal engine
step by step by step by step so it's
kind of like what we did here
but the 15 to 20 minute version
hitting every step along the way
with all of my fine tweaking and
refining already done right so i'm just
gonna try and get you guys there as
quickly and as efficiently as possible
so that comes out i believe on saturday
july 25th
uh don't miss it
it's gonna be a good one and
yeah keep creating keep having fun guys
i'll hang out with you for the next five
and then i'm gonna get some pizza
pizza
i need water if you guys got questions
hit at punisher
here and uh
and i'll answer
hypoxia no videos today
apologies
[Music]
no videos today
hmm
oh it feels good like i was saying guys
it feels good to
to work on
an environment throughout the week to
get it done to get it looking nice
and
to it also prep for the stream at the
same time so i feel like i know what i'm
doing the stream just goes a lot
smoother
when i do that i'm just happier with the
art but yeah let's let's try and get
will foshay on here let's try and do an
environment we'll will foshay together i
think it'd be sweet
and we can all do environments together
um
almost a million subscribers i know i
know we're so close i think by the time
we do the next community challenge which
is coming up
pretty soon ish here
next community challenge
we got the prompt me and the moderators
we got the prompt
just gonna start building the project
files
we're gathering the sponsors we're
getting the prizes together
so
get ready y'all
it's gonna be another one month
challenge you know the deal
get the montage together
do a nice little judging session with
some guests
all renders top 100 custom music
it's gonna be good
it's gonna be good
uh favorite pizza topping pepperoni man
pepperoni
and his pineapple justified i used to
think
absolutely get this pineapple off my
pizza but you know what i think i had
the most problem with was the ham i hate
i hate ham get the ham off my pizza
i willingly order pepperoni pineapple
jalapeno and basil pizzas
that's a move now you know
it's good
[Music]
did i okay ghost trigger did i figure
out how to get the contrast saturation
uh
uh brightness parameters added to my
material instance i did not
i did not that is something that i'm
going to add to
um
it's part of the research i'm doing for
my next pre-edited tutorial that's
coming out on july 25th i'm gonna try
and get that included in that video
there's lots of little things lots of
little tips and techniques to be uh
talked about
um
in that next video in two weeks so it's
on the list no doubt
sipo yeah soda's in the ear dude he's
talking to me he's telling me everything
i'm saying
he is saying to me
a fraction of a second
but
oh my god i can't talk when you do that
we gotta get a mic for soto so we can
pop in here i think that'll be great um
can you give us a hint to the community
challenge topic
soto what do you think mods what do you
think
can we give the tiniest hint
or shall we not shall we just say it's
coming and to be excited
[Music]
i don't know
one letter of the name m
m that is it starts with an m
that gives you nothing absolutely
nothing in fact you're more confused at
this point
you know we'll dish out some info as we
get closer all right we're going to hype
it up like we did last time
we're going to hype the release date
we're going to hype the name
um shout outs to visual
for um for for really wanting to do that
i think it's a great idea um he put
together some cool promo stuff for the
last challenge and we're working on
we'll be working on some stuff this time
too
yeah it's gonna be sick it's gonna be
sick it's not the america challenge no
no it's not that
uh it's not macro it's not masculine men
challenge it's not the morbius mark
twain challenge it's not the meat
challenge it's none of that stuff guys
it's none of that stuff
it's not morbid time
no
no it's not the macaroni challenge
confirmed
it's not that okay i promise
am i a pro artist
i mean pen sketching on a 2d sheet and
how do you apply it to hold on no
zykro okay am i pro artist who knows
what's the definition of a pro artist i
don't know what the definition of a pro
artist is who knows if i'm a pro artist
i just like making art uh i i mean pen
sketching on a 2d sheet
i don't know what you mean by that
but i will i will uh infer that
you're talking about
a little wacom tablet perhaps
they have the paper version of this
where you actually overlay paper and
there's a special pen where you draw on
the paper and the paper like your
drawing transfers to photoshop it's
pretty crazy
um it's the intuos pro 5 paper version
freaking sick
uh and then how do i apply that skill to
3d art how do you apply pen sketching to
3d art well
i don't know i mean i think
learning the piano would help you play
the trumpet better
because you're learning music theory
where the notes are
chords scales
patterns
all that good stuff and i'm sure drawing
helps with 3d art i'm sure it does
i love drawing
i think for me
my first instinct on how drawing helps
3d art would probably be
one it helps you come up with stuff off
the top of your head
two if you're drawing stuff that exists
it trains you to look at what you're
creating
so you're always using reference and
using references the one of the freaking
biggest parts of creating 3d art or any
art is there always have a reference
know where you're going
know where you're going just like in
civilization 6 a game i've been playing
recently
am i going for a domination victory am i
going for a culture victory you know um
religious victory you're gonna play the
game
very differently based on what victory
type you're going for
same with 3d
the art you're creating
is going to be vastly different you can
create anything anything so having a
having a north star having a guiding
point on what you're trying to go for
through reference is a great
it's great it's a must honestly
how that relates to art to art and
drawing and
drawing your reference there's a million
there's a million ways to relate it a
million ways
i'm gonna get that pizza pretty soon
you say pro equals getting paid to do it
ian
can you be pro and not be paid to do it
that's the question
i think
maybe yeah depending on your skill like
if you're so good
so good
um but you're not being paid to do it
either anymore or
you have never been paid to do it are
you a pro
yeah i don't know
it's conundrum
yeah visual talking about drawing you
learn about light form shape composition
of course yeah there's so much to be
taken from drawing
am i wearing vesis no i am wearing socks
the red square looks like i have a
health bar it kind of does doesn't it
that's my stamina bar or my
my uh my water intake bar
[Music]
i mean i don't know what else to do at
this point guys like we we did it all
we're just making the video longer for
people who want to learn how to make 3d
art and they're going to be like four
hours
i'm not gonna watch a four-hour video
[Music]
look at this look at this
rococo sent me a plan y'all for getting
married
yes
that's a little terrarium i want to
model this i want to
render this thing oh yeah i got married
got married
big big deal big moves
pretty sweet pretty freaking sweet
um
guys i think that's it you know we had a
good stream you guys are amazing thanks
for hanging out with me we got 400
people just listen to me rant and go on
and on
uh you guys are great keep learning keep
growing y'all know you'll know what to
do
weekly challenge in the discord down
below sign up on the discord uh it's
free sign up freaking subscribe of
course that's free
uh don't miss the community challenge
coming out in
very soon ish you guys just stay tuned
alright stay tuned
um what else
july 25th i got a video coming out on
how to
make more environments in unreal engine
and make them look photo real and make
them look nice step by step by step um
so it'll be like the shorter version of
this but with a new environment
a new environment
i'm gonna bounce it's pizza time you
guys are great thank you so much
catch you soon
stay safe stay healthy
peace out guys later
bye
[Music]
tip
[Music]